This is a podcast, and we're talking with people about talking. We're talking about stuff. We're talking about stuff that people like, like, life. Like, like, like, like, like, like life. It's smartless. Smart Less Smart
这是一个播客，我们正在和人们谈论谈话。我们在谈论一些事情。我们在谈论人们喜欢的东西，比如，生活。比如，比如，比如，比如，比如，比如生活。这是Smartless。Smart Less Smart
Less I watched episode 5 last night of Black Rabbit Oh Sean, you know what You're such a good friend I'm 6, 780s Oh sorry, hang on one second, well When you
Less 我昨晚看了《黑兔》的第5集，哦肖恩，你知道吗，你真是个好朋友，我6, 780s，哦抱歉，等一下，嗯，当你
I finished it last night Okay You did? I watched them all No Start with Ozark. No, sorry, I did it. I did it.
我昨晚看完了，好的，你看了吗？我把它们全看了，不，从《黑钱胜地》开始，不，抱歉，我做到了，我做到了。
I got it. Ozark, I am so close to watching Ozark. I know, I know. Dude, I'm so excited. First of all, I watched Ozark. I'm close to seeing your movie for the third time. But listen. Why?
我明白了。《黑钱胜地》，我离看完《黑钱胜地》很近了。我知道，我知道。伙计，我太兴奋了。首先，我看了《黑钱胜地》。我快要第三次看你的电影了。但是听着。为什么？
By the way, I haven't seen it. No, I know. But you're an incredibly supportive friend, so no doubt you will. Oh, yeah. I'll see it. Of course I will. You know what I actually did? I actually said.
顺便说一句，我还没看过。不，我知道。但你是一个非常支持我的朋友，所以毫无疑问你会看的。哦，是的。我会看的。我当然会。你知道我实际上做了什么吗？我实际上说了。
No, no, sorry, I was talking to Sean. Oh. Yeah. If that wasn't already clear. Listener, just give us a second. Go ahead, Chewy. What were you going to say? Chewy.
不，不，抱歉，我是在和肖恩说话。哦。是的。如果那还没说清楚的话。听众们，请给我们一秒钟。继续，Chewy。你想说什么？Chewy。
Chewy. I got a lot of issues with Will Arnett this morning. Oh, no, not really. I love Will Arnett. Will Arnett's my favorite. I would just say I'm flying to New York next week, and I'm downloading all the episodes, and I was going to watch it last night.
Chewy。今天早上我对威尔·阿奈特有很多意见。哦，不，其实没有。我爱威尔·阿奈特。威尔·阿奈特是我的最爱。我只是想说我下周要飞往纽约，我正在下载所有的剧集，我本来打算昨晚看的。
But Black Rabbit is very intense from everybody that I've heard. It's very intense, and I don't watch intense stuff before bed. Is that true? Well, you're going to have to watch it. Quite literally don't. You're going to have to watch it at night because I like low lighting on set. Yeah, it's really cool. But sorry, your plan was to watch it on a laptop, there on a computer, there on a plane.
但是根据我听到的每个人的说法，《黑兔》非常紧张。它非常紧张，我不喜欢在睡前看紧张的东西。那是真的吗？嗯，你得看它。字面意思上不要。你得在晚上看它，因为我喜欢片场光线暗一点。是的，这真的很酷。但抱歉，你的计划是在飞机上的电脑上用笔记本电脑看它。
No, on my iPad. So the third time I see your film, I'll see it in another movie theater like I did the first two times and really focus. Is it a feature film or is it a limited series? It's a limited series. Okay, thank you so much, caller. So I thought maybe the least you could do is watch it on the television at your house. We got a sig alert. We got a sig alert over on the four-over.
不，在我的iPad上。所以第三次看你的电影时，我会像前两次一样在另一家电影院看，并真正专注于它。它是长篇电影还是限定剧集？它是限定剧集。好的，非常感谢，来电者。所以我以为你至少可以在家里的电视上看。我们收到了Sig警报。我们在四号公路上收到了Sig警报。
It's really good. Can I come and watch it in your theater? You sure can. That would be fun. I'm going to watch the last two. Wait, Sean, you watch the last two? He watched the first two in the theater. He watched the first two in the theater.
它真的很好。我可以去你的影院看吗？你当然可以。那会很有趣。我要看最后两集。等等，肖恩，你看了最后两集？他在影院看了前两集。他在影院看了前两集。
The last two, yeah. But you watch it there on your, what, you got a 13-inch laptop with a couple of earpods? Let me just see. You might not have my number. Let me just see. you were out of town. Wednesday, a open invite.
最后两集，是的。但你在那里看，用什么，你有一个13英寸的笔记本电脑和一副耳机？让我看看。你可能没有我的号码。让我看看。你出城了。周三，公开邀请。
Wednesday, Lakeside. Open invite. If you could somehow get through the first six episodes on your 13-inch laptop, you're welcome to come over
周三，湖畔。公开邀请。如果你能设法在你的13英寸笔记本电脑上看完前六集，欢迎你过来
for 7 and 8 with Sean. Yeah, let's do that. You think I'm on a 13-inch laptop? That's the worst thing you've ever said to me. What is it like a 50-inch laptop? That's the thing I get offended by. How is everybody doing?
和肖恩一起看第7和第8集。是的，我们就这么做。你以为我在用13英寸的笔记本电脑？这是你对我说的最糟糕的话。那是什么，50英寸的笔记本电脑吗？那是我感到被冒犯的事情。大家怎么样？
I'm doing really well. Sean, you're adjusting back to being in southern california yeah yeah finally just like the last two days are you off your jet lag yet yeah just like literally the last two days finally finally waking back up at like four in the morning like my regular schedule it's been a week over a week eight days how many pounds have come back onto your body i'm gonna this is a good question just yesterday i was like wow i gained four pounds already in a week no well i mean i don't know if it's just i'm full of whatever but yeah spaghetti yeah I mean, I just had another...
我做得很好。肖恩，你适应回到南加州了吗？是的，是的，终于，就像过去两天一样，你的时差倒过来了吗？是的，就像字面意思上过去两天一样，终于，终于在凌晨四点左右醒来，就像我正常的作息一样，已经一周了，超过一周，八天了，你的身体长了多少磅？我要，这是一个好问题，就在昨天，我还在想，哇，我一周内已经胖了四磅了，不，嗯，我的意思是，我不知道是不是因为我吃得太饱了，但是的，意大利面，是的，我的意思是，我刚刚又吃了……
He's got some colon back up. You just had a what? I just had a piece of cake, a pumpkin cake with... Well, because I lost so much weight, I could just eat kind of... Right, sure. A couple things.
他的结肠有些堵塞。你刚刚吃了什么？我刚刚吃了一块蛋糕，南瓜蛋糕，配上……嗯，因为我瘦了很多，所以我可以随便吃点……对，当然。几样东西。
Well, but what was happening as you were losing weight was you were approaching your proper weight. But you said, no, no, don't get too close. Let's get it back up. Sorry, Sean, are you drinking cake right now? Remember the cake shake from Partillo? Oh, yes. Isn't that a great idea?
嗯，但当你减肥时发生的事情是你正在接近你合适的体重。但你说，不，不，别太接近了。让我们把它长回来。抱歉，肖恩，你现在在喝蛋糕吗？还记得Partillo的蛋糕奶昔吗？哦，是的。那不是个好主意吗？
He grinded up a cake and put it in a milkshake, so it's a cake shake. It was so good. I heard they got that from an anonymous tip from Glen Ellen, Illinois. You know what you ought to do. Put the cake in the shake. Shawnee, did you say you had a piece of pumpkin cake already this morning? It's not yet. No, it's just past 9.30.
他把蛋糕磨碎放进奶昔里，所以它是蛋糕奶昔。它太好吃了。我听说他们是从伊利诺伊州格伦埃伦的一个匿名举报中得到的灵感。你知道你应该做什么。把蛋糕放进奶昔里。肖尼，你说你今天早上已经吃了一块南瓜蛋糕了吗？还没到。不，刚过9点半。
Yeah, a pumpkin cake, a huge piece of pumpkin cake with my tea. My tea with milk and sugar. I know there is pumpkin cake. I want some pumpkin cake. Yeah, pumpkin cake with cream cheese frosting. It's so good. It tastes like fall. Come down.
是的，一块南瓜蛋糕，一大块南瓜蛋糕，配上我的茶。我的加奶加糖的茶。我知道有南瓜蛋糕。我想要一些南瓜蛋糕。是的，配奶油芝士糖霜的南瓜蛋糕。太好吃了。尝起来像秋天。过来吧。
How did you get that? Did you make that? No, I bought it from Trader Joe's. Remember when you were making yummy stuff for a little while last year? I'll do it. You want me to do it again? Remember you made a cheesecake? Yeah, I was sending you recipes from the New York Times.
你是怎么弄到的？是你做的吗？不，我从缺德舅（Trader Joe's）买的。还记得去年你有一段时间在做美味的东西吗？我会做的。你想让我再做一次吗？还记得你做过芝士蛋糕吗？是的，我当时在给你发《纽约时报》的食谱。
And I made them. Oh, God. Okay, I'm going to start sending them. All right. Well, you know, it's a per- The fact that I'm- Speaking of sweet treats. Yes.
然后我做了。哦，天哪。好吧，我要开始发了。好的。嗯，你知道，这是一个……事实上我正在……说到甜点。是的。
Good, nice, nice. Very good. And tea. And tea. It's a British guest? Yes. Is a very good friend and I love him. and you guys love them.
好，不错，不错。非常好。还有茶。还有茶。这是位英国客人吗？是的。是一位非常好的朋友，我爱他。你们也爱他。
Daniel Day Lewis. And you guys are friends with him too. My guest today has been obsessed with movies since he was a kid. His parents dropped him at the cinema at the cinema because it was cheaper than a babysitter. At 14, he was charging classmates
丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯。你们也是他的朋友。我今天的嘉宾从小就对电影着迷。他的父母把他扔在电影院，因为这比请保姆便宜。14岁时，他向同学收费
for his homemade action films, working supermarket jobs to buy reels, staying up till 3 a.m. for late night horror. When he finally got his first... Danny Boyle. When he finally got his first VCR, he was watching six movies a day. Since then, he's made zombies lovable,
拍摄他自制的动作片，打超市工买胶卷，熬夜到凌晨3点看深夜恐怖片。当他终于得到他的第一台……丹尼·博伊尔。当他终于得到他的第一台录像机时，他每天看六部电影。从那时起，他让僵尸变得可爱，
turned small town cops into action. Some heroes turned a pub crawl into the end of the world. Please welcome, my brilliant, honor to call a friend, Edgar. I knew it. Really got it very early. Very early. I knew it. Will got it after one sentence straight away.
把小镇警察变成了动作英雄，把酒吧巡游变成了世界末日。请欢迎，我才华横溢、我很荣幸称之为朋友的人，埃德加。我就知道。真的很早就猜到了。很早。我就知道。威尔一句话就猜到了。
I knew it. Edgar, I knew it. God, it's so funny. I was talking about you yesterday with my son. We were talking about Sean of the Dead, and then they were like, have you ever seen Hot Fuzz? I was like, guys, I am decades ahead of you. Have I seen Hot Fuzz? Before they were born.
我就知道。埃德加，我就知道。天哪，太搞笑了。我昨天和我儿子谈起你。我们在谈论《僵尸肖恩》，然后他们说，你看过《热血警探》吗？我说，伙计们，我比你们领先几十年。我看过《热血警探》吗？在他们出生之前。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I don't know whether I should be flattered or it's just predictable that, like, Sean Bessie said, he likes movies and Will said, Edgar Wright. I know, right, right? I know, how did you get that so fast? Either you, Quentin, or James Gray?
是的。是的。是的，我不知道我是该受宠若惊，还是这只是可以预见的，就像肖恩·贝西说他喜欢电影，而威尔说埃德加·赖特。我知道，对吧？我知道，你是怎么猜得这么快的？要么是你，昆汀，还是詹姆斯·格雷？
No, you know what, Edgar, you know, it's funny? One of the, the reason I was talking about you with my son, my 15-year-old, is we were talking about films and stuff that he liked, and we showed them, Sean of the Dead and Hot Foy, well, not Hot Foy's, but Sean of the Dead, and when they were quite young, because I was like,
不，你知道吗，埃德加，你知道，这很有趣？我昨天和我儿子，我15岁的儿子谈论你的原因之一，是我们当时在谈论电影和他喜欢的东西，我们给他们看了《僵尸肖恩》和《热血警探》，嗯，不是《热血警探》，而是《僵尸肖恩》，当他们还很小的时候，因为我当时想，
this is my idea of a perfect movie. Because you know, and I love you, and I love that film, and it's still so, it's still so, oh, you know what we were talking about, how brilliantly you had people panicking in the background, and Sean and those guys had no idea. And I was like,
这是我心目中完美的电影。因为你知道，我爱你，我爱那部电影，它仍然是那么，它仍然是那么，哦，你知道我们在谈论什么吗，你让人们在背景中惊慌失措的方式是多么精彩，而肖恩和那些家伙却一无所知。我当时想，
it's such brilliant filmmaking. So that's how it came up. Oh, thank you. I think it's important to have, I mean, I'm not a parent, not yet, but like to have horror films that you can show to kids. Yeah. I think my parents would allow me and my brother to watch things
这真是精彩的电影制作。所以这就是话题的由来。哦，谢谢。我认为拥有，我的意思是，我不是父母，还没当过，但拥有可以给孩子们看的恐怖片很重要。是的。我想我的父母会允许我和我哥哥看一些
that were like sci-fi-related, but something like Halloween or Friday the 13th would be off the table. But Alien and The Thing were okay because they had a sort of fantasy sci-fi element. What about The Exorcist? I can't believe I was allowed to see that. No. Yeah.
像科幻类的东西，但像《月光光心慌慌》或《13号星期五》这样的东西是不可能的。但《异形》和《怪形》还可以，因为它们有一种奇幻科幻元素。那《驱魔人》呢？我不敢相信我被允许看那个。不。是的。
What about... Have you seen weapons? Weapons is about kids that disappear. I love that movie. Would you let kids go see that? I mean, I would. I mean, you have different, in the UK, as you probably know, the ratings are different. So you can't do the thing that you do in the States where a parent or guardian could take you into a PG-13 or an R.
那……你看过《武器》吗？《武器》是关于失踪儿童的。我喜欢那部电影。你会让孩子们去看吗？我的意思是，我会的。我的意思是，你有不同的，在英国，正如你可能知道的，分级是不同的。所以你不能像在美国那样，父母或监护人可以带你去看PG-13或R级电影。
Right. Like a 15 is a 15 and an 80s and 18. So when I was, there used to be a cinema around the corner from my house where I grew up and probably from the age of like 12 to like 15, 12 to 13 I was trying to get into 15 rated films and doing that thing where you would be so dumb like I mean I remember the films I got into and I remember the films I didn't get into
对。比如15级就是15级，18级就是18级。所以当我，我长大的地方附近曾经有一家电影院，可能从12岁到15岁，12到13岁，我一直在尝试进入15级电影，做那种你会表现得很蠢的事情，我的意思是，我记得我进去过的电影，也记得我没进去过的电影
like I couldn't get into aliens I couldn't get into the fly and then I read that you you changed your voice to act yes you know the two things I would do to pretend to be older than I was was
比如我进不去《异形》，进不去《变蝇人》，然后我读到你改变了你的声音来表演，是的，你知道我为了假装比实际年龄大而做的两件事是
affected deeper voice and also wear hair gel wear product in my hair I thought that was something adults did. But it didn't, sometimes it didn't work. One time, though, I'd tell you the first 15 I ever got into was Gremlins was rated 15 in the UK. Because in the US, it was one of the first PG-13s, right?
装出更深沉的声音，还有涂发胶，在头发上用产品，我以为那是成年人会做的事。但它没有，有时它不起作用。不过有一次，我告诉你我进入的第一部15级电影是《小魔怪》，在英国被评为15级。因为在美国，它是第一批PG-13电影之一，对吧？
And me and my brother, I was 10 and my brother was 12, we went up to the cinema manager with a copy of the novelization of Gremlins and said to the manager, hey, we've already read the book, so we know what happens. so we're not going to be scared, so you should let us in. And it was a matinee, and it was pretty quiet,
我和我哥哥，我10岁，我哥哥12岁，我们拿着一本《小魔怪》的小说版走到电影院经理面前说，嘿，我们已经读过这本书了，所以我们知道会发生什么。所以我们不会害怕，所以你应该让我们进去。那是一场日场，而且相当安静，
and the manager looked around and said, get in there. And it was honestly the most exciting screening of my life because at any moment you thought somebody's going to come in and say, you shouldn't be in here, you're not 15. Oh, my God. That's great. I love that. You know, hey, before I forget,
经理环顾四周说，进去吧。那真的是我一生中最激动人心的放映，因为你随时觉得会有人进来，说，你不应该在这里，你不到15岁。哦，天哪。太棒了。我喜欢那个。你知道，嘿，在我忘记之前，
because it's such a great question, and my brain doesn't work good. Do you guys celebrate Halloween over there? It's not as big as it is in L.A., but then if I have one bugbear about Halloween, is that in Los Angeles, it seems to go on for three fucking months. Yeah.
因为这是一个很好的问题，而且我的大脑不太好用。你们那边庆祝万圣节吗？它不像在洛杉矶那么盛大，但如果我对万圣节有什么不满的话，那就是在洛杉矶，它似乎要持续三个该死的月。是的。
I know. I mean, Halloween starts at the end of August. It's ridiculous. Yeah, I know. But it struck me that you would probably be a great costume maker, thinker. What was your best Halloween costume you've ever put together? Ah. And did you go to the prosthetics department there?
我知道。我的意思是，万圣节从八月底就开始了。太荒谬了。是的，我知道。但让我印象深刻的是，你可能是一个很棒的服装制作人、思考者。你做过的最好的万圣节服装是什么？啊。而且你去那里的假肢部门了吗？
Yeah. to get some appliances put on. Appliances. You know what I've done? You know what? When I've been living in LA sometimes, I used to resent the fact that you'd need to get more than one costume. Halloween would be like a four-day weekend,
是的。去装上一些假体。假体。你知道我做了什么吗？你知道吗？当我在洛杉矶生活时，有时我会怨恨你需要准备不止一套服装的事实。万圣节就像一个四天的周末，
and it's like, I'm going to do one costume. I think my favorite one I ever did, and this will appeal to you guys, because this is also, this was, in the way that you showed Sean of the Dead to your kids, this was a film that was dear to me when I was too young to see it, is I went to a Halloween party in L.A.
就像，我要做一套服装。我想我做过的最喜欢的一套，这会吸引你们，因为这也是，这是，就像你给孩子们看《僵尸肖恩》一样，这是一部我在太小而不能看的时候就对我意义重大的电影，我去参加洛杉矶的一个万圣节派对
as David Norton from America World Wolf in London. Oh, God. Really? Oh, wow. She's a real deep cut costume. Yeah, it is. What that's, J.B., what was your best costume ever? No, we've done. Team Wolf 2, right?
装扮成《美国狼人在伦敦》里的大卫·诺顿。哦，天哪。真的吗？哦，哇。这是一个非常冷门的服装。是的，它是。那是什么，J.B.，你做过的最好的服装是什么？不，我们做过。《狼人2》，对吧？
Team Wolf 2. Close. Team Wolf also. Close. I went as Jason Bateman, which... You did it. I did, which meant that I wore the, a hockey goalie mask for Jason,
《狼人2》。接近了。也是《狼人》。接近了。我装扮成杰森·贝特曼，这……你做到了。我做到了，这意味着我戴了，一个曲棍球守门员面具代表杰森，
and a net over my body with a bunch of hooks and lures on it for Bateman and I thought I was a genius. I was so disgustingly proud of it. Oh my God, wait a second, let's spend some time. Yeah, I was like 19, I just like tapped everyone on the shoulder saying, hey man, guess who I am? It was a total embarrassment.
身上披着一张网，上面挂着一堆钩子和诱饵代表贝特曼，我以为我是个天才。我对此感到恶心地自豪。哦，天哪，等一下，让我们花点时间。是的，我当时大概19岁，我只是拍拍每个人的肩膀说，嘿伙计，猜猜我是谁？这简直太尴尬了。
Shawnee, Shawnee? I mean, that is embarrassing. I told you one that I think I already told you when I went a static cling one year, but then I went as, and then when I was a kid, Yeah, when I was a kid, my mom let me go as a hooker. I went as a, I dressed up as a hooker. Wow. Yeah. And what that looked like?
肖尼，肖尼？我的意思是，那确实很尴尬。我告诉过你一个我认为我已经告诉过你的，我有一年装扮成静电吸附，但后来我装扮成，然后当我还是个孩子的时候，是的，当我还是个孩子的时候，我妈妈让我装扮成妓女。我装扮成，我打扮成妓女。哇。是的。那看起来像什么？
And did you work? No, I mean, she got me like... How much you make? Was it successful? She got me like a boa and like a jacket. Like, no questions asked. I'm like, lady, you're not going to ask any questions? My first year in New York, 1990, and I didn't really celebrate it that much before.
你工作了吗？不，我的意思是，她给我买了……你赚了多少钱？成功吗？她给我买了像围巾和夹克之类的东西。就像，没问任何问题。我心想，女士，你难道不打算问任何问题吗？我在纽约的第一年，1990年，我之前并没有真正庆祝过它。
And I agree with you, Edgar, too. I'm a bit of a bahambug when it comes, when it's not. Not kids for Halloween, a little bit. I love it. But I went as Bobby Peru from Wild at Heart. Oh, wow. Did you tell William Defoe that when he was on? I don't think I did I tell him?
我也同意你的观点，埃德加。当它不是的时候，我有点像个扫兴的人。不是万圣节的孩子，有一点。我喜欢它。但我装扮成《我心狂野》里的鲍比·秘鲁。哦，哇。你告诉威廉·达福了吗，当他来的时候？我不认为我告诉他了？
Bobby Peru. What a name. I took Dracula teeth that you just buy it at a Halloween store. And then I melted them down so they were straight across. I wore a bolo tie. Wait, who's Bobby Peru? What was that from? William Defoe's character.
鲍比·秘鲁。多好的名字。我拿了你在万圣节商店买的德古拉牙齿。然后我把它们熔化了，这样它们就是平的。我戴了一条波洛领带。等等，鲍比·秘鲁是谁？那是出自哪里？威廉·达福的角色。
William Defoe's character from Wild at Heart. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Terrifying. Terrifying teeth are horrific. The teeth are terrifying, yeah. The problem was I had to explain it to everybody. It's just such a boozy holiday, isn't it? It is a boozy holiday.
威廉·达福在《我心狂野》里的角色。哦，是的，是的，是的。太可怕了。可怕的牙齿很恐怖。牙齿很可怕，是的。问题是我必须向每个人解释它。这真是一个酗酒的节日，不是吗？这是一个酗酒的节日。
You really got to drink into it. Wait, I want to know, Edgar, I had the pleasure of meeting Oscar, your older brother, on the set of The Running Man, which will get to later. Oh, yes, the running. This is a preemptive. This is a film I want to see. In the blind applause. No, I mean, I just watched it the other day.
你真的得喝进去。等等，我想知道，埃德加，我有幸在《过关斩将》的片场见到了你的哥哥奥斯卡，我们稍后会谈到。哦，是的，过关斩将。这是一个先发制人的。这是一部我想看的电影。在盲目的掌声中。不，我的意思是，我前几天刚看了。
We'll get to it later, but it's fucking incredible. It's incredible. I'm sure. Yeah, it's, I was blown away. But wait, I want to talk about Oscar. Was, did that, how, were you guys close when you were young? And did he have the same love that you had for movies and stuff? Yeah, very much.
我们稍后会谈到它，但它他妈的太不可思议了。它不可思议。我相信。是的，它，我被震撼了。但等等，我想谈谈奥斯卡。那是，那，你们年轻时亲近吗？他和你一样热爱电影之类的东西吗？是的，非常。
I mean, my brother, he's two years older. I think we went through that difficult period as teenagers where I think from the ages of like 14 to 17, we hated each other's guts. And then we got thick as thieves again immediately afterwards. And he's worked on all of my movies as well. So he's amazing. So it's really great to have that relationship. But there was a period where we hated each other.
我的意思是，我哥哥，他大两岁。我想我们经历了青少年时期那段困难时期，我想从14岁到17岁左右，我们恨透了对方。然后在那之后我们立刻又变得像贼一样亲密。他也参与了我所有的电影制作。所以他很棒。所以拥有那种关系真的很棒。但有一段时间我们互相憎恨。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. As teenagers do. Of course, of course. Edgar, where did your love of? And then I assume shortly thereafter the skill at creating such exciting visuals in films along with your ability to tell story and have performances and all that other stuff. And music.
是的，是的，是的。青少年常有的事。当然，当然。埃德加，你的爱来自哪里？然后我假设不久之后，在电影中创造如此令人兴奋的视觉效果的技巧，以及你讲述故事和拥有表演以及所有其他东西的能力。还有音乐。
And music, yeah. But yeah, so you're, do you, can you attribute it to one particular film that you saw and you're like, that's the kind of style I want to learn about because you're just so incredible at using every department. You know, often directors specialize in one. But on all of them, you're just, you seem to have so much fun making movies. I think it was, my parents were both. artists and art teachers, and I think they got me and my brother interested in cinema
还有音乐，是的。但是，是的，所以你，你能把它归因于你看过的一部特定电影，然后你就像，那是我想学习的那种风格，因为你太擅长利用每个部门了。你知道，导演通常专攻一个。但在所有这些方面，你似乎在制作电影时玩得很开心。我想是，我的父母都是艺术家和艺术老师，我想他们让我和我的哥哥对电影产生了兴趣
early on. And they were very supportive parents, because I'm not from like a, you know, a rich background or anything. And I had no connections within the industry. But my mom and dad, like, you know, would just kind of like encourage us to sort of go for it, even though there was no clear path to being in film. So I think that the thing was of starting with like a Super 8 camera and just making like amateur films and sort of just. fucking around like um but i think the and and so it was that thing of like knowing i wanted to be in film but not knowing exactly how to do it and the only way you could really like force yourself into doing it was just making films with your friends and trying and watching things and trying
很早。他们是非常支持我的父母，因为我不是来自那种，你知道，富裕的背景之类的。我在行业内没有任何人脉。但我妈妈和爸爸，就像，你知道，只是鼓励我们去尝试，尽管没有明确的电影之路。所以我认为关键在于从像超8毫米摄像机开始，只是制作业余电影，只是像……胡搞，嗯，但我认为，而且，所以那是那种知道我想从事电影工作但不知道具体怎么做的事情，而你真正能强迫自己去做的唯一方法就是和你的朋友一起制作电影，尝试并观看事物，并尝试
to figure out how they did it and doing the zero budget version of it so then was that mostly it the fact that you had a little camera when you were a little kid and you're really too young to kind of grind about performance and crap like that you're really like looking like like whip whip pans and strong pushes and all that stuff. Because you had a little camera and you didn't have Dolly tracker or anything, you're just like on your shoulder. And it's a much more visual effort, right? As a little kid, I bet.
弄清楚他们是怎么做的，并做零预算版本。所以那主要是因为你小时候有一台小摄像机，而且你太年轻了，不能去磨练表演之类的东西，你真的像是在看像鞭扫和强力推镜头之类的东西。因为你有一台小摄像机，而且你没有任何轨道车之类的东西，你只是在你的肩膀上。这是一个更具视觉效果的努力，对吧？作为一个小孩子，我敢打赌。
Yeah, I mean, I remember making, I won a video camera on the BBC when I was 16. I'd entered this competition that was part of Comet Relief. And I won, and I won a video camera, which I previously wouldn't admit I would to afford. But as soon as I had that, it was kind of like my, you know, kind of, you know, like school sort of went out of the window a little bit, and I was just this, like, amateur filmmaker, like, making sort of films in free periods. But I would make things like I would make, I would make, like,
是的，我的意思是，我记得我16岁时在BBC赢得了一台摄像机。我参加了这个作为“喜剧救济”一部分的比赛。我赢了，我赢了一台摄像机，我之前不会承认我买得起。但一旦我有了它，就像我的，你知道，学校生活有点被抛在脑后了，我只是这个，像，业余电影制作人，像，在空闲时间制作电影。但我会制作东西，就像我会制作，我会制作，就像，
I didn't have a steady cam, so I would make, like, a fake sort of cradle with, like, a ceiling tile and string and, like, run around with it during time. To answer your question, though, Jason, I tell you, a lot of filmmakers that were really big to me, beyond, like, you know, Stephen Spielberg and George Lucas, But there was a particular time of like when I was sort of growing up in the 80s of people that meant a lot to me were like, John Carter, Joe Dante, John Landis. And then when I was like in my, maybe you're at 15, I think there was the year that I saw
我没有斯坦尼康，所以我制作了一个，像，一个假的摇篮，用天花板瓷砖和绳子，像，在时间里带着它跑来跑去。不过回答你的问题，杰森，我告诉你，很多对我来说非常重要的电影制作人，除了，像，你知道，斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格和乔治·卢卡斯，但在80年代我成长过程中，对我意义重大的特定时期的人，像约翰·卡特、乔·丹特、约翰·兰迪斯。然后当我大概15岁时，我想那一年我看了
Raising Arizona by the Coen Brothers and Evil Dead 2 by Sam Ramey in quick succession. And those were real like mind blowers to me in terms of like, oh my God, look how much fun these guys are having in film. It was so infectious, both of those movies, one of which is a comedy, one of which is a comedy horror. But they have a lot in common, and those guys were friends as well, and colleagues. But, like, just what they did with the camera and how they got, like, just magic and infectious enthusiasm out of every frame.
科恩兄弟的《抚养亚利桑那》和山姆·雷米的《鬼玩人2》，接连不断。那些对我来说真的是令人大开眼界，关于，哦，天哪，看看这些家伙在电影里玩得有多开心。那太有感染力了，两部电影都是，其中一部是喜剧，其中一部是喜剧恐怖片。但它们有很多共同点，那些家伙也是朋友和同事。但是，就像，他们用摄像机所做的事情，以及他们如何从每一帧中获得，像，纯粹的魔力和感染力的热情。
Those were like... I've got to see Evil Dead, too. I haven't seen it so long. Significantly better than Evil Dead One? Oh, it's just... You haven't seen the second one? Don't know it, yeah. Oh, it's fun. It's a blast.
那些就像……我得看《鬼玩人2》。我好久没看了。比《鬼玩人1》好得多？哦，它只是……你没看过第二部？不知道，是的。哦，它很有趣。它太棒了。
It's kind of like they just decided, let's remake the first film and put more Three Stooges in it. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Edgar, I love that in my notes it says, you made a clay animation when you got that camera about wheelchair. Claymation, sorry. They usually just put it together.
这有点像他们只是决定，让我们重拍第一部电影，并在里面加入更多的“三个臭皮匠”。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。埃德加，我喜欢我的笔记里说，当你得到那台摄像机时，你制作了一个关于轮椅的粘土动画。粘土动画，抱歉。他们通常只是把它放在一起。
Combine the two. Yeah, they bunch of it. it. They bundle it. Amy Poehler taught us to bundle, right? Bundle, yeah. I got to take that into consideration. You made a claimation about wheelchair access. Is that what it was?
结合两者。是的，他们把它捆绑在一起。艾米·波勒教我们捆绑，对吧？捆绑，是的。我得考虑一下。你制作了一个关于轮椅通道的粘土动画。是那样的吗？
Yeah, that was the thing for Comet Relief. Yeah, it's so funny. I mean, what was that? What about wheelchair access? I mean, why that? I think I had seen something. There was a film program in the UK. I guess it was probably film, 91 at the time,
是的，那是为“喜剧救济”做的东西。是的，太搞笑了。我的意思是，那是什么？关于轮椅通道？我的意思是，为什么是那个？我想我看到过什么东西。英国有一个电影节目。我想当时可能是《电影91》，
but they had a thing about the lack of wheelchair ramps in the cinema. So I did like a, I did an animation. about it for comic relief. Oh, that's great. So that was when I was on TV when I was like 16 years old. And one of the things, it's a funny thing about that.
但他们有一个关于电影院缺乏轮椅坡道的事情。所以我做了一个，我做了一个关于它的动画，为了“喜剧救济”。哦，那太棒了。所以那是我16岁时在电视上播出的。而且其中一件事，关于那个有一件有趣的事。
And actually, you can find the clip on YouTube. One of the weird things, imagine being on live TV for the first time, and they accidentally told me the night before that I'd won. And then somebody, a researcher, oh, he's not supposed to know that. So then imagine having this pressure
实际上，你可以在YouTube上找到那个片段。奇怪的事情之一，想象一下第一次上直播电视，他们前一天晚上不小心告诉我我赢了。然后有人，一个研究员，哦，他不应该知道那个。所以想象一下有这种压力
of being on TV as a 16-year-old. Then they say, tomorrow, when you're on the show, pretend like you haven't won. So when they say that you've won, that you've won, you have to act like you're really surprised. That's a lot of pressure on that national TV. If you see that clip, if you see my amazing acting of, like, who me?
作为一个16岁的人上电视。然后他们说，明天，当你在节目上时，假装你还没赢。所以当他们说你赢了，你赢了，你必须表现得好像你真的很惊讶。那在全国电视上有很大的压力。如果你看到那个片段，如果你看到我惊人的表演，像，谁，我？
Oh, I love that. That's great. If anybody wants tips on how to act like you never won, just ask me. Hey, listen. Well, that's going to change. That's going to change after this movie. You know, we, Edgar, we got to know each other back kind of around China of the Dead Days. And you introduced us to our dear friend,
哦，我喜欢那个。太棒了。如果任何人想要关于如何表现得像你从未赢过一样的技巧，尽管问我。嘿，听着。嗯，那会改变的。那部电影之后会改变的。你知道，我们，埃德加，我们在《僵尸肖恩》时期就认识了。你把我们介绍给了我们亲爱的朋友，
who were also friends with Pete Sera Finowicz, which was through you and Simon and everybody. I know, all these great dudes. And it was in that time that you recommended that I really wanted to watch a show that I've told so many people about that to me is just such an example of a really great show, great writing, great directing, great acting, which is spaced and is not as heralded as it should be. and I urge anybody who wants to watch a show
我们也是皮特·塞拉菲诺维茨的朋友，那是通过你和西蒙以及所有人。我知道，所有这些伟大的家伙。就是在那个时候，你推荐我真的想看一部我告诉过很多人关于它的节目，对我来说，它只是一个非常好的节目、伟大的写作、伟大的导演、伟大的表演的例子，那就是《屋事生非》，它没有得到它应有的赞誉。我敦促任何想看节目的人
that's really original and really funny to go and watch Spaced that you directed with the great Simon Pegg and Nick Frost. Yeah, and Jessica Heinz. I mean, incredible. How did that come about? Well, I was, yeah, I had basically,
真的很原创而且真的很有趣，去看看你和伟大的西蒙·佩吉和尼克·弗罗斯特导演的《屋事生非》。是的，还有杰西卡·海因斯。我的意思是，不可思议。那是怎么来的？嗯，我当时，是的，我基本上，
I got my break into the industry. I had made a film when I was 20. I went to art college for two years, and then I made a really low-budget film called A Fist Full of Fingers that were shot on 16-mill, which cost like 30 grand total. Just full of fingers.
我进入了行业。我20岁时拍了一部电影。我上了两年艺术学院，然后我拍了一部非常低成本的电影叫《拳头》，是用16毫米胶片拍摄的，总共花了3万英镑。全是手指。
It did get, it got released at the cinema in the UK. And like, I say cinemas. It was released in a cinema, a one screen. But I, but through that I got into TV,
它确实在英国的电影院上映了。而且就像，我说电影院。它是在一家电影院上映的，一个屏幕。但是，我，但通过那个我进入了电视，
it was first through, like, Matt Lucas and David Walliams. They were doing a cable show, and I was directing that when I was 21. And then a couple of years later, I worked with Simon, Pegg, and Jessica Heinz for the first time.
首先是通过，像，马特·卢卡斯和戴维·威廉姆斯。他们在做一个有线电视节目，我21岁时在导演那个。然后几年后，我第一次和西蒙·佩吉以及杰西卡·海因斯合作。
And then spaced, I was 24 when I did Spaced. Wow. Wow. That's amazing. It seems, I realize now, I knew it at the time that it was really special, but now I really just, I feel so thankful that, like, I can't believe I was directing, like, a show that was on network TV when I was 24.
然后《屋事生非》，我做《屋事生非》时24岁。哇。哇。那太棒了。似乎，我现在意识到，我当时就知道它非常特别，但现在我真的只是，我感到非常感激，就像，我不敢相信我在24岁时就在导演像网络电视上的节目。
And actually, I got to say, actually, I want to say thanks to all of you. Will, I remember when I first came to L.A., you and Amy, when you were both so generous to me and just would sort of take me. And the first time I met both of you, actually, was at a dinner that Will brought me to, but I just I went in reference space because I remember something that you did because I came and visited the set
而且实际上，我得说，实际上，我想感谢你们所有人。威尔，我记得我第一次来洛杉矶时，你和艾米，你们俩对我都很慷慨，只是会那种带我。我第一次见到你们俩，实际上是在威尔带我去的一次晚餐上，但我只是引用了《屋事生非》，因为我记得你做过的一些事情，因为我来参观了片场
of the rest of development it must have been a season three episode I don't remember which one it was but I remember Bob Einstein was in it and I went on set but I remember Will you did this prank that when I came to so Space was this sitcom that I did
《发展受阻》一定是第三季的一集，我不记得是哪一集了，但我记得鲍勃·爱因斯坦在里面，我去了片场，但我记得威尔你做了这个恶作剧，当我来到……所以《屋事生非》是我做的情景喜剧
on Channel 4 which is one of the main channels in the UK and it was out on DVD but you couldn't get it in the States yet so kind of like comedy nerds like yourself would get kind of copies of it and have to have a region free player
在英国的第四频道，这是英国的主要频道之一，它出了DVD，但你在美国还买不到，所以像你们这样的喜剧书呆子会得到它的副本，并且必须有一个无区域播放器
and I came to the arrested development set and I went to Will's trailer and Will you had inside of your trailer you had the DVD cover of space photocopied and plastered absolutely everywhere and then he turned around and he said oh I didn't know you were coming that's great
我来到《发展受阻》片场，我去了威尔的拖车，威尔你在你的拖车里，你把《屋事生非》的DVD封面复印并贴得到处都是，然后他转过身说，哦，我不知道你要来，那太棒了
which says everything about you is extremely silly thing to do and I really appreciate it. Yeah, I remember we all met at a restaurant in Venice or something and that's when Will said, you gotta watch this movie Sean on the Dead and I watched it right away and yeah, that's when we first met. It was so long ago.
这说明了关于你的一切，非常愚蠢的事情，我真的很感激。是的，我记得我们在威尼斯的一家餐馆见面，那时威尔说，你一定要看这部电影《僵尸肖恩》，我立刻就看了，是的，那是我们第一次见面。那是很久以前的事了。
Yeah, 20 years ago. It was through all that and then look around you and you really opened my eyes. Actually, you kind of in addition to space, so many of the other things you were really my entree to stuff because we didn't, as you said, we didn't get a lot of those shows, and you recommended so many things that really opened
是的，20年前。是通过所有这些，然后看看你周围，你真的打开了我的眼睛。实际上，除了《屋事生非》，你其他的很多东西真的成了我进入这些东西的入口，因为我们，正如你所说，我们没有得到很多那些节目，你推荐了这么多东西，真的打开了
my eyes to a lot of the great stuff that they do in the UK, and I've never looked back. I've been an anglophile ever since. I want to say one thing that, like, this has never been mentioned on this podcast before, I don't think so. But Jason, in the UK, in the sort of mid-80s,
我的眼睛，看到了他们在英国做的很多伟大的事情，我从此再也没有回头。我一直是个亲英派。我想说一件事，像，这在播客上从来没被提到过，我不这么认为。但是杰森，在英国，在80年代中期，
they actually showed, and I was a fan of, It's Your Move. Oh. Yeah. It's true. And I remember specifically, and I've mentioned this you before, the episode that I remember, and this would be a real deep cut Halloween costume. There's an episode where you have to pretend like a
他们实际上播放了，而且我是粉丝，《It's Your Move》。哦。是的。这是真的。而且我记得特别清楚，我之前跟你提过，我记得的那一集，这会是一个非常冷门的万圣节服装。有一集你必须假装像一个
rock band is coming to school. The dregs of humanity. The dregs of humanity. He remembers that. He remembers that. It's insane. Well, I'd like to pitch that next Halloween the four of us should go as the dregs of humanity to a party and have to explain
摇滚乐队要来学校。人类的渣滓。人类的渣滓。他记得那个。他记得那个。太疯狂了。嗯，我想提议下个万圣节我们四个应该装扮成人类的渣滓去参加派对，并且必须向那里的每个人解释
it to every single person there saying, we're doing a bit from It's Your Move. Come on, it's your move. I loved It's Your Move too. I loved It's Your Move too. I watched it. I watched it. I did too. I was like, this kiddie's such a bad kitty, so sort of, you know, just doing shit.
它，说，我们正在做《It's Your Move》里的一个片段。来吧，这是你的举动。我也喜欢《It's Your Move》。我也喜欢《It's Your Move》。我看了。我看了。我也看了。我当时想，这孩子真是个坏孩子，所以那种，你知道，只是在做烂事。
It was cool. Yeah, guys. So then after, wait, I did want to, I wanted you to tell this one thing about fistful of... Well, I wanted to ask about space, sir, just while we're on space. I remember you told me one time, Edgar, and tell me if I'm wrong, that you, when you and Simon were putting it together in Jessica and you didn't know, and Nick had never acted before. Is that true? Nick Frost? Oh, that's right.
它很酷。是的，伙计们。所以在那之后，等等，我确实想，我想要你讲关于《拳头》的这一件事……嗯，我想问关于《屋事生非》，就在我们谈论《屋事生非》的时候。我记得你曾经告诉我，埃德加，如果我错了请告诉我，你，当你和西蒙在整理它时，还有杰西卡，你不知道，而且尼克以前从未演过戏。是真的吗？尼克·弗罗斯特？哦，那是对的。
how that came about? Nick had never acted before and there was a... What's the version of SAG in the UK is like the spotlight? Which is like the kind of actors' union. And there was another actor called Nick Frost in the union.
那是怎么来的？尼克以前从未演过戏，而且有一个……英国的演员工会版本是什么，像Spotlight？就像演员的工会。工会里还有另一个叫尼克·弗罗斯特的演员。
Because the Channel 4 weren't really going to take a chance on somebody who had no credits. So we said, oh yeah, no, he's been in all these other shows. No. We pretended he was the other Nick. So apologies to the other Nick Frost.
因为第四频道真的不会冒险用一个没有任何作品的人。所以我们说，哦是的，不，他演过所有这些其他节目。不。我们假装他是另一个尼克。所以向另一个尼克·弗罗斯特道歉。
No fucking way. It's true. No way. And he could keep his name. Yeah. I think, I'm not sure. Maybe the other Nick Frost changed his name. And Simon, maybe you were Andrew Simon told me,
没门。是真的。没门。而且他可以保留他的名字。是的。我想，我不确定。也许另一个尼克·弗罗斯特改名了。而西蒙，也许你是安德鲁·西蒙告诉我的，
like Simon worked with him at a restaurant maybe, and he said he was his funny friend, and he was like he was funnier than everybody else I knew. He worked at a Mexican restaurant, which is not really a thing in the UK, as you probably know, called Chiquitos. I remember he wasn't, he'd never acted before and he would do this thing and he kept doing this on Sean of the Dead that I would sometimes give him a direction
就像西蒙可能在一家餐馆和他一起工作，他说他是他有趣的朋友，而且他说他比我认识的任何人都更有趣。他在一家墨西哥餐馆工作，正如你可能知道的，在英国这并不是什么大事，叫Chiquitos。我记得他不是，他以前从未演过戏，他会做这件事，而且他在《僵尸肖恩》里一直这样做，我有时会给他一个指导
and Nick Frost would walk up to me and whisper in my ear and say, please remember, I am not an actor. That's great. And that continues to this day. I love that. So funny. So wait, so the fistful of fingers, somebody gave you $11,000 to make that?
尼克·弗罗斯特会走到我身边，在我耳边低语说，请记住，我不是演员。太棒了。而且这种情况一直持续到今天。我喜欢那个。太搞笑了。所以等等，所以《拳头》，有人给了你11,000美元来制作它？
Yeah. I mean, it was, um, I owe it all to a newspaper editor in my hometown, Mike Matthias, who had some, I think he had just come into an inheritance, so he had some tax loss money. So we made the whole thing on 11 grand, and then we raised another, like,
是的。我的意思是，它是，嗯，我把它归功于我家乡的一位报纸编辑，迈克·马蒂亚斯，他有一些，我想他刚刚继承了一笔遗产，所以他有一些税收损失资金。所以我们用11千美元制作了整部电影，然后我们又筹集了另外，像，
maybe it was the cost, the whole thing cost $22,000, actually. Wow. But yeah, it was like sort of shot it over, like, 20 days on 16 mill. It was all starring, like, my school friends and my college friends. It didn't actually occur. to me that there might be actors around. In fact, the only actor that's in it, who's from Ted Lassau,
也许是成本，整件事花了22,000美元，实际上。哇。但是，是的，它就像那种在20天内用16毫米胶片拍摄的。它全是主演，像，我的学校朋友和大学朋友。它实际上并没有发生。对我来说，周围可能有演员。事实上，里面唯一的演员，来自《泰德·拉索》，
James Lance is in the movie, and the any reason that he's in the movie is that he, his mom heard that in the local paper that some kids are making a movie. And he said, oh, I'm an actor. And I said, oh, sure, you could be in it. That was how the casting works.
詹姆斯·兰斯在电影里，他出现在电影里的唯一原因是，他，他妈妈在当地报纸上听说一些孩子在拍电影。他说，哦，我是个演员。我说，哦，当然，你可以参与。这就是选角的工作方式。
That's great. It was very, it was like 78 minutes long with credits. Here's a good story. I had to pad it out. The movie, as you all know, having made, directed and, you know, and written, is that you usually have the assemble edit, for Tracy, the assembly edit is when the whole, all of the takes of the movie are put together. So, like, usually an assemble edit might be hours and hours long.
太棒了。它非常，它有78分钟长，包括演职员表。这是一个好故事。我不得不把它填满。这部电影，正如你们都知道的，制作过、导演过，而且，你知道，写过，是你通常有组装剪辑，对于特雷西，组装剪辑是当整部电影的所有镜头放在一起时。所以，像，通常组装剪辑可能会有几个小时长。
But the assemble edit of fistful of fingers, the whole thing with every single shot was like 75 minutes long. And it meant that I couldn't really cut it down. Which was, there were some bits I wanted to cut out. All the shitty parts need to stay in. Yeah, so here's what I did. I needed, there was at least one, but I really wanted to cut out. I mean, now I probably cut another 25 minutes out.
但是《拳头》的组装剪辑，整件事加上每一个镜头只有75分钟长。这意味着我不能真正把它剪短。这，有些部分我想剪掉。所有糟糕的部分都需要留下来。是的，所以这就是我做的。我需要，至少有一个，但我真的想剪掉。我的意思是，现在我可能会再剪掉25分钟。
But at the time, to cut some bits out, I basically created a scene in the dark. In the middle of the movie, there's a scene where it's a Western, so they're cowboys around a campfire, and they blow out the fire. And so I thought, I could just put a whole, like, scene in black here to pad it out for two minutes. So I just put like, just black film and just like they just talked for two minutes in the dark and that was my way of padding it out. Oh, wow, that's a good idea. Long end credits, long, only credits.
但在当时，为了剪掉一些部分，我基本上在黑暗中创造了一个场景。在电影中间，有一个场景，这是一个西部片，所以他们在篝火旁有牛仔，他们吹灭了火。所以我心想，我可以在这里放一个完整的，像，黑色场景来填补两分钟。所以我只是放了像，只是黑色胶片，就像他们在黑暗中谈话了两分钟，那就是我填补它的方式。哦，哇，那是个好主意。长片尾字幕，长，只有字幕。
Yeah. So smart. That's great. So from there, after Spaced, you did what's known as the Cornetto trilogy now, which is Sean of the Dead, Hot Fuzz, and the World's End with your friends. I mean, it's a dream for everybody to just kind of work with their friends
是的。太聪明了。太棒了。所以从那里开始，在《屋事生非》之后，你做了现在被称为“血与冰淇淋三部曲”的作品，也就是《僵尸肖恩》、《热血警探》和《世界尽头》，和你的朋友们一起。我的意思是，对每个人来说，只是和他们的朋友一起工作是一个梦想
and you did it three times in these like incredible movies. one after another. Was that working title on all three of them? Yeah. Yeah, Eric Fauna. Tim Bevan. Nira Park, who you well know, Jason as well, did all of the movies. I mean...
你连续三次执导了这些不可思议的电影。是一部接一部。这三部电影的制片方都是Working Title吗？是的。没错，埃里克·费尔纳（Eric Fellner）、蒂姆·贝文（Tim Bevan），还有你很熟悉的尼拉·帕克（Nira Park），杰森你也认识，他们制作了所有的电影。我是说……
Yeah, and Liza Chason. Yeah, and it was straight after... I say after the second series of Spaced, we started writing Sean. I mean, it was funny. It was never meant to... It's funny, it's called the Cornetto Trilogy, because a cornetto for the American listeners is a brand of ice cream in the UK, in Europe, in fact,
是的，还有丽莎·查森（Liza Chason）。没错，那是在……我是说在《屋事生非》（Spaced）第二季之后，我们开始写《僵尸肖恩》（Shaun of the Dead）。那很有趣。它本意并不是……有趣的是，它被称为“血与冰淇淋三部曲”（Cornetto Trilogy），因为对于美国听众来说，Cornetto是英国乃至欧洲，实际上是世界上大多数地方的一种冰淇淋品牌，除了美国。
in most of the world, except. the States. Is it three layers? It's just a, no, it's, no, it's not, it's like different flavors. It's like a pre-packaged ice cream cone, isn't it? Yeah. It's like a drumstick. Yes.
除了美国。它是三层的吗？不，不是，它只是……它有不同的口味。它就像一个预包装的冰淇淋甜筒，对吧？是的。就像一个Drumstick冰淇淋。没错。
The only reason it came up as a trilogy is when we did Sean of the Dead, which mentions Cornetto once, we got free ice cream at the premiere, and I said to Simon when we were writing hot fuzz, hey, we should write cornettos into the second one, so we get free ice cream again. That's great. I love that. How did you and Simon meet? Because that was, you guys, it's been a sort of a lifelong collaboration, you guys.
它被称为三部曲的唯一原因是，我们在拍《僵尸肖恩》时提了一次Cornetto，结果在首映式上得到了免费的冰淇淋。所以当我们在写《热血警探》（Hot Fuzz）时，我对西蒙说，嘿，我们应该把Cornetto写进第二部，这样我们又能得到免费冰淇淋了。太棒了。我喜欢这个。你和西蒙是怎么认识的？因为你们俩的合作简直是终身的。
He says we met at the Battersea Art Center, and I know the truth is we met at the Riverside Studios. We met at a, he was friends with, there was in the, like, around that time, and I first moved to London, like, you know, 30 years ago, and there were a lot of people on the scene who have all now become huge, like the Mighty Bush guys, and, you know, Simon and Matt Luke's and David Williams and the League of Gentlemen guys, they were all sort of coming up around the same time
他说我们是在巴特西艺术中心（Battersea Art Center）认识的，但我知道真相是我们是在河畔工作室（Riverside Studios）认识的。我们是在一个……他当时和一些人是朋友，那是在我刚搬到伦敦的时候，大概30年前，当时圈子里有很多现在已经大红大紫的人，比如《神奇动物管理员》（The Mighty Boosh）的那帮人，还有西蒙、马特·卢卡斯（Matt Lucas）、大卫·威廉姆斯（David Walliams）和《绅士联盟》（The League of Gentlemen）的那帮人，他们都是在同一时期崭露头角的。
and I met Simon backstage at a comedy gig and I'd seen him doing stand-up on TV and he's from the same area as me we're only like, we grew up like 50 miles away from each other so we're both from the West Country and I'd seen him on TV doing a stand-up set about regional TV so I went up to him and said, hey, I'm from the West Country too
我在一场喜剧演出后台遇到了西蒙，我之前在电视上看过他的单口喜剧，他和我来自同一个地区，我们成长的地方相距只有50英里左右，所以我们都来自英国西南部。我在电视上看到他表演关于地方电视台的单口喜剧，所以我走过去对他说，嘿，我也来自西南部。
so I think he remembered me as who's that weird kid who's that weird kid with a beard And then you guys And then what happened? Oh, the lights are turning off in my room I have to, I just get the motion sensors on in here. Look at that. SOS.
我想他当时把我记成了“那个留着胡子的怪小孩是谁”。然后你们……后来发生了什么？哦，我房间里的灯关了，我得……这里的动作感应器启动了。看那个。SOS。
That's okay. I'm in the dark now. You're definitely not in the U.S. Are you in the holding cell? No, we're shooting the campfire scene. We're shooting the... Wait, so you guys... We can pat this out for two minutes.
没关系。我现在在黑暗中。你肯定不在美国。你在拘留室吗？不，我们在拍篝火场景。我们在拍……等等，所以你们……我们可以把这段剪掉两分钟。
So you guys meet and you say, hey, let's do a TV series? No, we... Oh, somebody's coming in to... There's somebody's switching the lights on for me. Thank you. There's motion sensors. I'm in a conference room.
所以你们见面后就说，嘿，我们来拍个电视剧吧？不，我们……哦，有人进来了……有人在帮我开灯。谢谢。这里有动作感应器。我在会议室里。
I'm actually mixing the running man right now. It is not finished. It's out on November 14th, and it will be finished by then. But Simon... Yeah, he was... I started doing TV, and I did this TV show on... I guess the British version of Comedy Central, the Paramount Comedy Channel at the time.
我其实正在混音《奔跑的人》（The Running Man）。还没完成。它将于11月14日上映，到那时会完成的。但是西蒙……是的，他当时……我开始做电视节目，我在……我想是英国版的喜剧中心，当时的派拉蒙喜剧频道（Paramount Comedy Channel）做了一个节目。
And there was a show called Asylum, and I got asked to direct it and Simon Pegg was in it and he brought Jessica Heinz who co-wrote Spaced and co-created Spaced onto that so I was working with them for the first time so I'd already met him
有一个叫《Asylum》的节目，我被邀请去执导，西蒙·佩吉（Simon Pegg）在里面，他带来了杰西卡·海因斯（Jessica Hynes），她是《屋事生非》的联合编剧和联合创作者，所以我第一次和他们一起工作，所以我之前就认识他了。
and I knew then it's funny when you meet somebody that you think I'm gonna I thought even then like this is eight years before we made the movie I was thinking I'm going to make a movie and he's going to be in it I knew then that Simon was like
那时我就知道，当你遇到一个人，你会想……我当时就想，那是我们拍电影的八年前，我就在想，我要拍一部电影，他会参演。那时我就知道西蒙是一个伟大的喜剧男主角，剩下的只是找到合适的点子。是的，太棒了。我简直不敢相信你正在混音，你已经给出你的意见了吗？
a great comedy leading man and it was just about then finding the idea of what that was yeah it's so great I'm so I'm so I'm so I can't believe you're at a mix right at doubt have you already given your notes
他们在休息时正在落实你的意见，你还在做这个播客。是的，这听起来很高级，说大家现在要去处理最小的细节。
they're implementing your notes in that break you're doing this podcast yeah it's very fancy to say guys are gonna go and do smallest right now yeah
这很高级，你在做混音，他们就像……他们在说什么？天哪，那是什么？混音工作量很大，对吧？
it's very fancy you're doing a mix they're like what they're like what what are you talking about yeah what the hell is that mix is enormous right
肖恩看过这部电影了，是的，这是一个复杂的庞然大物。确实。是的，我的意思是，这太不可思议了。好吧，在我们进入……
it's well Sean has seen the movie yeah it's a it's a complicated beast massive I'm sure. Yeah, I mean, it's so incredible. Well, before we get to,
我们马上会谈到，在谈到那个之前，我想说的最后一件事是《极盗车神》（Baby Driver），因为《极盗车神》是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一，我看过很多遍。而且，是的，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。
and we're going to get to it, the last thing I wanted to say before we get to that, is Baby Driver, because Baby Driver is one of my favorite movies of all time, and seen it so many times. And, yes, bravo, bravo, bravo.
我之前不知道这个，直到……他们让那个孩子开车！这部疯狂的电影，那个孩子在开车。Bambino，开车。我本来希望你会说Bambino。我本来希望你会说Bambino。当然。
And I did not know this until I... They let the baby drive! This crazy movie, the baby is driving. A Bambino, drive. I was hoping you were going to say Bambino. I was hoping you were going to say Bambino. Of course.
我说了。他说了。安德鲁，我不知道你曾经或现在还有耳鸣。是真的吗？不，我年轻时有过。就是那种耳朵里听到高频声音，或者尖锐噪音之类的。但那实际上是……你知道，耳鸣患者，或者我们在英国称之为Tinnitus。这是一个奇怪的词，就像……
I did. He did. Andrew, I didn't know that you had or still have Tinnitus. Is that true? No, I had it when I was young. Which is when you hear high-pitched things in your ears and, yeah, pitch noises and stuff. But it was something that actually, you know, Tinnitus sufferers or Tinnitus, as we call it in the UK. It's one of those weird words like...
Aluminum（铝）。Aluminum。Aluminum。Aluminum。Resorto，Risotto（意大利调味饭）。不，我年轻时有过……但我并没有……你知道，电影中角色用来用音乐屏蔽耳鸣的方法，显然不是我在八九岁时能想出来的，但确实，我以前确实有过。
Aluminum. Aluminum. Aluminum. Aluminum. Resorto, risotto. No, I had it when I was young and... But I didn't, you know, like the thing that... the character does in the film to sort of like tune out the tinnitus with music was not something obviously that I could figure out when I was, it was happened when I was probably like eight or nine, but it was, yeah, I did used to have that.
所以当那种想法再次出现时，而且认识很多人，显然音乐界很多人都有耳鸣。所以我确实有这方面的经验，但现在没有了。哦，太好了。我的意思是，希望不要再有了。你是什么时候变得……我会说，对音乐如此痴迷的，因为你给我发过，或者现在还在发你的年度播放列表。是的，我听了，它涵盖了所有媒介，所有……
So it was something when that kind of idea came back around and knowing people, obviously a lot of people in the music industry have tinnitus. So it was, it was, I had experience of it, but not anymore. Oh, good. I mean, hopefully not again. And when did you become, and I'll say the, obsessed with music because you sent me or you still send me your yearly kind of yes end of your playlist yeah and i listen to it and it's so it covers all mediums all
各种类型的音乐。你第一次听一张专辑或一首歌，然后就爱上它，是什么时候？嗯，我想大概就是……你知道，我父母的黑胶唱片，在那个我们都还没老到记得电脑出现之前的日子里，嗯，你知道，电视上没什么节目的时候。我的意思是，我过去常常……我相信很多人都一样，放上披头士的《白色专辑》（White Album），看着它转动。是的。
kind of genres of music when did you first listen to an album or a song be like you just you love it well i think probably just you know my parents vinyl like in in the days before like we were all old enough to remember the days before like computers and um you know, when there's nothing on TV. I mean, I used to kind of, like, allow I'm sure, like, a lot of people, like, put the white album on and just watch it go around. Yeah.
所以，坐着看黑胶唱片转动。所以我一直是个超级音乐迷。我想这可能……我不演奏乐器，如果说我有什么遗憾的话，那就是我不会。我的意思是，我想我还是可以开始学的。永远都不晚。太晚了。
So, sit and watch the vinyl go around. So I've always been a huge music fan. I think it's probably one, I don't play an instrument, and I think it's one of, if I have a regret, it's that I don't. I mean, I guess I could still start. Never too late. Too late.
我永远不会成为像你那样的钢琴家，肖恩。虽然，如果我想弹钢琴，那会是我选择的乐器。我想弹。是的。我做不到你那样。你可以的。你可以的。但你的电影，你知道，在电影中运用了如此伟大的表达方式来展现你的音乐亲和力，对吧？
I'll never be a pianist like you, Sean. Although, if I would like to play the piano, that would be the instrument. I'd like to play. Yeah. I can't do it like you. You can. You can. But your films, you know, use such a great expression for your sort of musical affinity in film, right?
这是一种运用音乐的绝佳方式，你在电影中总是运用得如此有效。你对在电影中使用音乐的过程感到非常兴奋吗？我想我有一种电影音乐版的联觉，我只是想象它。比如，《极盗车神》在我的脑海里存在了大概20年，在我制作它之前，电影开场的那首歌，约翰·斯宾塞蓝调爆炸乐队（The Jon Spencer Blues Explosion）的《Bellbottoms》，我听到这首歌，我就能看到那个场景。
And it's such a great way to use music, and you do it always so effectively in your films. Do you get really excited by that process of using music in your films? I think I have the kind of movie music version of synesthesia where I kind of just imagine it. Like, Baby Driver sort of existed in my head. for maybe like 20 years before I made it where it was that song that opens the movie Bell Bottoms by the John Spencer Blues Explosion I would hear the song and I would see the scene
然后我不知道你们在写作时是否有这种感觉，你可以看到脑海中的电影，而困难的部分是把它写下来。所以我认为《极盗车神》是我脑海中看到的那些电影之一，在某个时刻，我必须弄清楚它是什么，以及我如何能把它拍成电影。
and then I don't know if you guys have this when you're writing is you can see the movie in your head and the difficult part is writing it down so I think Baby Driver is one of those films that I kind of saw in my head and at some point I had to figure out what it was and how I could make it into a film
所以那会是……我有时会这样做，在脑海中酝酿很长时间。音乐总是激发序列的东西。这就像我在拍的很多电影一样，一首歌会触发整个事情。
so that would have been I do that sometimes fermenting in my brain for a long time. And the music was always the thing that inspired the sequences. And it's something that like in a lot of the movies I've made is that like a song will sort of trigger the entire thing.
导演音乐录影带呢？你做过吗？因为我觉得在这个领域做这件事会非常令人兴奋。是的。很棒的东西。是的，我拍过音乐录影带。我的意思是，可悲的是，音乐录影带的预算在25年前就开始下降了。
What about directing videos? Have you done that? Because I'd imagine that would be a super exciting thing to do in this area. Yeah. Great stuff. Yeah, I have done music videos. I mean, the sad thing is that the kind of like the, you know, budgets for music videos started going down like 25 years
现在，你知道，它不像以前那样了，这真的很遗憾，因为显然有一些音乐录影带，比如米歇尔·贡德里（Michel Gondry）的作品，它们就像艺术品。它们应该放在博物馆里。它们太不可思议了。所以我拍过一些，虽然没有我想要的那么多，但我为Beck和L Williams拍过，我想拍更多，但它们很难制作，因为它们，你知道，如果你是为……预算如此受限，对吧？是的，就像很多人情债。你不能连续做太多次。我想我连续拍了两部低预算的音乐录影带。
ago and now, you know, like, it isn't a thing in the same way it was, which is a real shame because obviously there are some, like music videos like, well, Michelle Gondry, they're like works of art. They belong in a museum. They're incredible. Like, so I have done some, not as many as I'd like, but I've done ones for Beck and for L Williams and I'd like to do more, but they're difficult things to make because they, you know, if you're doing it for... So constrained as a budget, yeah? Yeah, it's like a lot of pulling favors. And you can only do that so many times in a row. I think I did two low-budget music videos in a row
就在《僵尸肖恩》之后。第二部之后我意识到，啊，你不能连续两次要求人们免费工作。或者相反，像你这样很多高级导演，在项目间隙会拍商业广告。因为预算很高，你可以用所有有趣的设备，和摄影师合作。
right after Sean of the Dead. And I realized after the second one is like, ah, you can't ask people to work for nothing twice in a row. Or the opposite of that would be a lot of fancy directors like you will, in between projects, we'll do commercials. Because the budgets are so high and you can get all the fun gear and work with the cinematographer.
你经常做那种事吗？没有我想要的那么多，但我的意思是，我认为这件事的关键还在于，如果你有一个你非常喜欢的剧组，要让他们保持工作。是的，是的。你知道，这是一件好事。甚至可能不是和新剧组合作。
Do you do a lot of that at all? Not as much as I'd like to, but I mean, I think also the thing with that is also, if you've got a crew that you really like, is to keep them working. Yeah, yeah. You know, and so that's a nice thing. It may not even be working with new crew.
有时是和你知道的剧组合作，正如你所知，电影之间可能间隔三年或四年。所以如果你有一个你喜欢合作的团队，拍商业广告和音乐录影带是大家保持合作的好方法。我的意思是，我认为这就是关键，因为我也写作。我总是羡慕那些一年能拍一部电影的导演，因为对我来说，电影之间至少间隔三年，通常当你拍完一部电影，你会想……
Sometimes it's working with the crew that, you know, as you know, it can be like three years between movies or four years between movies. So if you have a team of people that you like working with, doing commercials and music videos is a great way to all keep working together. I mean, I think that's the thing because I write as well. I'm always envious of directors who can kind of do a film a year because at minimum it's like three years between movies for me and usually when you finished a movie you kind of think like
哦，我们有一个很棒的团队，我们应该继续下去，但从来没有那样过。我从来没有直接投入到下一部电影中，因为你执导的每一部电影你都在写剧本，是的，我需要小睡一下。是的，是的，你……我记得你几年前说过，我们谈论某事时，你说不，不，我只能执导我写的东西，这是你唯一能理解它的方式，对吧？我的意思是，你一直坚持这一点。是的，到目前为止，我的意思是，我……这并不是说不会改变。
oh we've got this great team we should just keep going but it never works out like that you can't I've never rolled straight into another movie because you're writing everything you direct yeah and I need a nap yeah yeah yeah you I remember you saying that years ago we were talking about something and you said no no I only I only I can only direct the things that I write it's the only way you can kind of get your brain around it right I mean you've always held to that. Yeah, so far, I mean, I, I, that's not to say that wouldn't change.
而且，你知道，我……我不怎么写。我的意思是，《极盗车神》其实是我唯一独立写的东西，其他所有东西我都是和联合编剧一起写的，你知道，我喜欢那样，我喜欢这样做。但我不会排除那种可能。我……你知道，我认为这就是那种情况，你……我的意思是，这也很困难，比如《僵尸肖恩》这样的电影，如果只是读剧本，
And, you know, I, you know, I don't write a lot. I mean, Baby Driver is actually the only thing I wrote on my own, everything else I've written with co-writers, which, you know, like, and I love that, and I like doing that. But I wouldn't, I wouldn't rule that out. I, you know, I think it's that thing where you, you, I mean, it's really difficult as well with, like, something like Sean of the Dead was a film where to just read the script,
不知道我会如何执导它，或者西蒙和尼克会如何表演它，我想，你知道，一些演员拒绝了它，因为他们被它搞糊涂了，或者制片厂拒绝了它，因为他们看不出它的潜力。在某种程度上你……你们那种方式……
Without knowing how I would direct it or how Simon and Nick would perform it, I think, you know, some actors passed on it because they were just sort of baffled by it or studios passed on it because they couldn't quite see it. And in a way you... The way that you guys...
是的，你必须看到西蒙和尼克在表演，你必须看到他们自然主义喜剧表演的基调，因为你可以拿完全相同的剧本，把它拍得非常粗俗和愚蠢，那将是完全不同的电影。所以那部电影特别如此，而且《屋事生非》对我们有帮助，我们可以向人们展示《屋事生非》，说，
Yeah, you had to see Simon and Nick doing it and you had to see their tone of their naturalistic comedy performance because you could take exactly the same screenplay and make it really broad and silly and it would be an entirely different movie. So it was a thing with that film in particular, and it helped that we had spaced, and we could show people space and say,
嘿，它大概会是这个样子。但这对每个人来说都不是容易推销的，你知道。我肯定。我肯定。如果你那样看，它的目标很窄。它是一部喜剧。它是一部恐怖片。它是所有这些东西。而且在某些部分很愚蠢，
hey, this is what kind of what it's going to be like. But it wasn't an easy sell for everybody, you know. I'm sure. I'm sure. It's a narrow target, if you look at it that way. It's a comedy. It's a horror film. It's all of these things. And it's silly in parts in a way,
但你也必须有那些部分。我告诉你，伙计，电影史上我最喜欢的时刻之一，我向你发誓，我一直引用它，就是当每个人都被包围时，尼克站起来，该死的弗罗斯特接了一个该死的电话。是的。
but you also have to have those. I tell you, man, one of my favorite moments in film history, I swear to you, and I reference it all the time, is when everybody's surrounded and Nick gets up, fucking Frost gets a fucking phone call and he answers it. Yeah.
他就像，被僵尸包围了，对吧。是的。你还好吗？你怎么样？是的。他只是超级……在和他的毒贩说话。在和他的毒贩说话。
And he's like, surrounded by zombies, yeah. Yeah, you're all right? How you doing? Yeah. He's just super... Talking to his dealer. Talking to his dealer.
在这个伟大的高潮时刻，这太他妈搞笑了，然后被他接电话完全打破了。他接了。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。对你来说，有没有一个喜剧基调的“北极星”，我敢打赌是英国的，
It's so fucking funny in this great heightened moment and then it's completely burst by he gets a phone call. And he takes it. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Is there a comedic, tonal, like, North Star for you that, I'll bet is British,
在你成长过程中确立了你认为最有趣的喜剧类型？哦，是的，我的意思是，我想它们是……有一些节目，有些在我那个时代之前，但会被重播。我的意思是，我觉得那些真正具有开创性的节目。我的意思是，显然，蒙提·派森（Monty Python）在我那个时代之前，但它重播了很多，所以那会是……像《弗尔蒂旅馆》（Fawlty Towers）这样的东西。
that sort of established what you thought was the funniest kind of comedy when you were growing up? Oh, yeah, I mean, I think they were, like, there were shows, some of them before my time in the get repeated. I mean, I feel the shows that were really, like, the groundbreakers. I mean, obviously, Monty Python was before my time, but it was repeated a lot, so that would be. something like faulty towers 40 towers i mean the ones that were on tv when i was you know like things like 40 towers and
《弗尔蒂旅馆》，我的意思是那些在我小时候电视上播出的节目，比如《弗尔蒂旅馆》和……
are you being served was slightly before my are you being served was always on i love that show but i think the the first one that made a really big impact on me which is more of a culty show in the states was the young ones which was only like 12 episodes
《Are You Being Served?》稍微在我之前……《Are You Being Served?》总是播，我喜欢那个节目，但我认为第一个对我产生巨大影响的，在美国更像是一个邪典节目，是《The Young Ones》，只有12集。
which was so punk rock it was only 12 episodes i've never seen it was like So one series in 1982, one series in 1984, every episode ended with them dying. Like, it was such a sort of like... I love that show. It was like a total hand grenade of a show. And I remember I was too young to see it the first time at school,
它太朋克摇滚了，只有12集。我从来没看过。就像1982年一季，1984年一季，每一集结尾他们都死了。就像，它是一种……我喜欢那个节目。它就像一个完全的手榴弹式的节目。我记得我第一次在学校看时太小了，
but all of the kind of the cool kids at school were talking about the young ones. So when the second series came around, I was all over it. Remember, nature sows the seed. We plant the seed. Nature sows the seed. I remember that show. That was so good. I want to see it.
但学校里所有酷小孩都在谈论《The Young Ones》。所以当第二季出来时，我完全沉迷其中。记住，大自然播下种子。我们种下种子。大自然播下种子。我记得那个节目。太棒了。我想看它。
It was incredible that show. And it really, it really stands up. They used to have bands on every week. They, you know, they figured out they could get a bigger budget as a variety show if they had a band on. So randomly in the middle of a sitcom, like Motorhead would be on all of a sudden. It was such a weird, yeah, it was sort of,
那个节目太不可思议了。而且它真的很经得起时间考验。他们过去每周都有乐队表演。他们发现如果他们有乐队表演，作为综艺节目可以获得更大的预算。所以在一个情景喜剧中间，像摩托头乐队（Motorhead）会突然出现。这太奇怪了，是的，它是一种……
the format of it was so alien to what we were accustomed to. Well, certainly, you know, I don't know about the U.S., but Canada as well, so that when we, I remember seeing it, it was so jarring to watch the first time. time because it was so unlike anything else yeah yeah i think it was like that on british tv as well when it first came on i mean it was it was the start of something i mean alternative comedy as they called it in the 80s was like huge and there were like shows that that haven't traveled over to the u.s that uh you know i mean i guess in that pre kind of like cable age where things
它的形式与我们习惯的太不一样了。好吧，当然，你知道，我不知道美国的情况，但加拿大也一样，所以当我们……我记得看到它时，第一次看时太令人震惊了，因为它与任何其他东西都不同。是的，是的，我想它在英国电视上刚播出时也是这样。我的意思是，它是某件事的开始。我的意思是，80年代所谓的另类喜剧非常火，而且有一些节目没有传到美国，你知道，我的意思是，我想在那个前有线电视时代，事情
started traveling over in like 20 years ago but prior to that there'd be things like um the day-to-day and brass eye and alan partridge and um really those shows were like huge for me when you were when you were writing when you're writing comedy specifically do you find it helpful because you mentioned you wrote you write with other people
在20年前开始传播，但在那之前，会有像《The Day Today》、《Brass Eye》和《Alan Partridge》这样的节目，我的意思是，这些节目对我来说真的太重要了。当你写作时，当你专门写喜剧时，你觉得有帮助吗？因为你提到你和别人一起写，
and you've written with Simon a lot do you writing comedy do you find it helpful to write with somebody else oh yeah in terms of sort of for sort of pace and sort of for tone and all these things and for jokes obviously I think writing comedy on your own
你和西蒙写了很多，写喜剧时，你觉得和别人一起写有帮助吗？哦，是的，在节奏、基调和所有这些方面，当然还有笑话。我认为独自写喜剧
is a very lonely business I think writing with a co-writer and pinging things off each other or just reading it aloud. I think that's a big thing is just reading the script aloud to each other and you get to the point where you could almost perform it like a play. I think, you know, Baby Driver I wrote on my own
是一件非常孤独的事情。我认为和联合编剧一起写，互相碰撞想法，或者只是大声朗读。我认为这是一个大问题，就是互相大声朗读剧本，你会达到几乎可以像戏剧一样表演它的程度。我想，你知道，《极盗车神》是我自己写的，
but that was more of an action film and it was the most difficult script to write because you're constantly looking for, you know, affirmation from somebody like, please somebody read the pages at the end of the day. But, you know, obviously with writing with Simon Pegg or Michael Bacall or Joe Cornish, you know, like... You have immediate feedback.
但那更多是一部动作片，它是最难写的剧本，因为你一直在寻找，你知道，来自某人的肯定，比如，请某人在一天结束时读一下这些页面。但是，你知道，显然和西蒙·佩吉、迈克尔·巴考尔（Michael Bacall）或乔·科尼什（Joe Cornish）一起写，你知道，就像……你有即时的反馈。
Pinging off each other. Yeah, because if you write something, you're like, oh, this is kind of a funny bit. And if you're running with somebody else and you sort of go, yeah, and then the guy, blah, blah, blah, blah. And you're writing with it goes, yeah, it's pretty good. And you're like, okay, well, yeah, that's a terrible idea. Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
互相碰撞。是的，因为如果你写了一些东西，你会想，哦，这有点好笑。如果你和别人一起跑，你可能会说，是的，然后那个人，巴拉巴拉巴拉。和你一起写的人说，是的，这很好。你会想，好吧，是的，那是个糟糕的主意。是的，是的，是的，完全正确。
I mean, I'd like to write something else like that, and me and Simon keep talking about writing something else together. I wish you would. It really just comes down to just being in the room together, really. It's just like we've got to do that and just hash it out and have fun with it, you know? Okay, speaking of writing with somebody, you had a writing partner on The Running Man. I want to talk about The Running Man. I'm so excited for everybody to see this.
我的意思是，我想再写点别的东西，我和西蒙一直在谈论一起写点别的东西。我希望你们会。这真的归结为在同一个房间里，真的。就像我们必须那样做，把它搞定，玩得开心，你知道吗？好吧，说到和某人一起写，你在《奔跑的人》里有一个写作伙伴。我想谈谈《奔跑的人》。我太兴奋了，每个人都能看到这个。
It's so good. I was blown away. And listeners, Sean P. Hayes is in this film. Sean is in The Running Man. I did it to hang out with Edgar, and it was a blast. It was so fun. And you're in the ones, the only scene in the movie that Glenn Powell is not in. I know, right?
太好了。我被震撼了。听众们，肖恩·海耶斯（Sean P. Hayes）在这部电影里。肖恩在《奔跑的人》里。我这样做是为了和埃德加待在一起，这太棒了。太有趣了。而且你是电影中唯一一个格伦·鲍威尔（Glenn Powell）不在的场景。我知道，对吧？
I know. No, is that, do you requested that, Sean? That's an odd. No, Glenn requested that. Oh, Glenn did. Glenn specified. By the way, I spoke to Glenn for a long time yesterday and went on and on about how incredible he is.
我知道。不，那是你要求的吗，肖恩？那很奇怪。不，格伦要求的。哦，格伦要求的。格伦指定的。顺便说一句，我昨天和格伦谈了很久，一直在说他有多不可思议。
He is so commanding and so, I said, the greatest gift, a compliment I could give you, and I gave it to Jason, too, on Black Rabbit, is there's nothing lazy about it at all. There's nothing at all. Fully committed, fully into it. he's like a huge action star glen paul i mean hands down like you buy every single thing he says it's it's he's amazing this movie looks huge yeah it's huge it's so good and um i remember just to
他太有统御力了，而且，我说，我能给你的最好的礼物，赞美，我也给了杰森，在《黑兔》（Black Rabbit）上，就是它一点也不懒。一点也不。完全投入，完全沉浸其中。他就像一个巨大的动作明星，格伦·鲍威尔，我的意思是毫无疑问，你相信他说的每一句话，他太棒了。这部电影看起来很大。是的，它很大。太好了，而且……我记得刚开始的第一天，我太尴尬了，我开了一些愚蠢的玩笑，比如我要和剧组建立联系，让他们喜欢我，没想过他们已经在那儿待了14个小时，当我来排练时，我说了个愚蠢的玩笑，没人笑，我当时想，哦天哪，这会他妈的太糟糕了。然后我掉进了舞台下的洞里。没人记得那个，其实。不。他们现在记得了。他们现在记得了。而且我
start off the first day i was so embarrassed i made some stupid joke like i'm gonna connect with the crew and make them like me not thinking they'd already been there for 14 hours when i can for rehearsal and they i said some stupid joke and nobody laughed i was like oh god this is gonna be fucking awful. And then I fell into the hole off the stage. Nobody remembers that, actually. No. They do now. They do now. And I
感谢上帝没受伤，但我当时想，哦天哪，我掉在……你试图和剧组建立联系的那个笑话是什么？我说，电影获得绿灯的原因在这里。哦，不。我现在记得了。行走的绿灯已经到达。
thank God it didn't hurt, but I was like, oh my God, I fell on, I fell on the... What was the joke that you tried to connect with the crew? I said, the reason the movie got, Greenlit is here. Oh, no. I remember that now. The walking green light has arrived.
所以，但无论如何，这很棒。你很棒。我必须纠正一件事，杰森。我们必须一起工作，因为我现在已经和这个电话里的三个人中的两个合作过了。我有耐心。哦，是的。我在我的《刑房》（Grindhouse）预告片里做了配音，别。而且肖恩在《奔跑的人》里。
So, but anyway, it was great. You were great. I have to rectify something, Jason. We have to work together because I've now worked with two of the three people on this call. I'm patient. Oh, yes. I did a voiceover in my grind house trailer, don't. And Sean is in the running man.
所以，杰森，我必须，我必须凑齐一套。没有什么比这更让我开心的了。好吧，我可以拍张照吗？《人类残渣》（Dregs of Humanity），这部电影。《人类残渣》，或者这是你的下一部电影。这是你的下一步。那个角色现在在做什么？《狼人3》（Teen Wolf 3）和3D。
So, Jason, I have to, I have to complete the set. Nothing would make me happier. Okay, can I make a picture? Dregs of Humanity, the movie. Drags of Humanity, or it's your next movie. It's your next move. What's that character doing now? Team Wolf 3 and 3D.
我们做吧。你怎么拼写3？是的，那是个很棒的。哦，有几个E。上面有太多E了。好吧，谈谈《奔跑的人》，因为它太不可思议了。你是从11月拍到3月，对吧？
Let's do it. How are you spelling 3? Yeah, that's a great. Oh, there's a few E. There's a few too many E's on it. Okay, so talk about the Running Man because it was incredible. It was you shot through November through March, right?
去年11月到3月。是的。是什么吸引了你？对于不知道的人，对于特蕾西，80年代有一部阿诺德·施瓦辛格主演的《奔跑的人》电影，而且，我没有……理查德·道森（Richard Dawson）。
Last November through March. Yeah. And what drew you to it? For people who don't know, for Tracy, there was a Running Man movie in the 80s with Arnold Schwarzenegger, and it's, I did not... Richard Dawson.
是的。还有理查德·道森，对。我当时不知道它是斯蒂芬·金的书。我不知道。我以为这是一个原创点子。是的，这是他用笔名理查德·巴克曼（Richard Bachman）写的书之一。
Yes. And Richard Dawson, right. And I did not know it at the time that it was a Stephen King book. I didn't know that. I thought it was an original idea. Yeah, it was one of the books he wrote under his pseudonym, Richard Bachman.
他在被发现之前写了大概五本小说。也许四本小说在被发现是理查德·巴克曼之前。这是一个他用来写非恐怖作品的笔名。所以《奔跑的人》写于1982年。
He wrote like five novels before he got rumbled. Maybe four novels before he got rumbled as Richard Backman. It was a pseudonym that he wrote for non-horror stuff. And so The Running Man was written in 1982. too. And the Schwarzenegger 87 version is a very loose adaptation of the books, which is one of the things that attracted me because I'd read the book as a teenager. I think probably like a lot of people, Stephen King was a real gateway author for me in the sense of I was reading his books in my early teens and it was probably some of the first grown-up books I ever read and the
而施瓦辛格87年的版本是对书的一个非常松散的改编，这也是吸引我的原因之一，因为我十几岁时读过这本书。我想可能像很多人一样，斯蒂芬·金对我来说是一个真正的入门作家，因为我在十几岁出头时读他的书，那可能是我读过的第一批成人书籍之一，而且
running man made a particular impression on me. And I'd actually read the book before I'd seen the Schwarzenegger film. So I was aware that it was drastically different. And so I was always interested in doing a new adaptation of it because I thought, well, this is a book that hasn't really been adapted. So, and I've also, like, a dream to adapt to Stephen King book. And, yeah, so it was, I mean, I, it's difficult for me to talk about when I'm still making it, but I, I mean, you've seen the movie, Sean,
《奔跑的人》给我留下了特别深刻的印象。而且我其实在看施瓦辛格的电影之前就读过这本书。所以我知道它有巨大的不同。所以我一直对制作一个新的改编版很感兴趣，因为我想，好吧，这是一本还没有真正被改编的书。所以，而且我也一直有一个梦想，改编一本斯蒂芬·金的书。而且，是的，所以，我的意思是，我……当我还在这部电影制作中时，很难谈论它，但我，我的意思是，你已经看过这部电影了，肖恩，
but it's been such a kind of adventure. It's also funny as well, like, it has some, one of the things. is why I want to say Glenn's in every scene except the one that Sean's in. Sean's in a show that Glenn is watching right at the start of the movie. He's a different game show that's not the running man.
但它一直是一种冒险。它也很有趣，比如，它有一些，其中一件事。就是为什么我想说格伦在每个场景里，除了肖恩在的那个。肖恩在电影开头格伦正在看的一个节目里。他是一个不同的游戏节目，不是《奔跑的人》。
But Glenn is in every scene because in the book, one of the things that was really intense about the book is that you see the entire thing through Ben Richards' point of view. And that was something that I thought, well, that's something
但格伦在每个场景里，因为在书里，书里真正激烈的一件事是，你通过本·理查兹（Ben Richards）的视角看到整个事情。那是我认为，好吧，那是
that's not in other movies like this. Usually they cut away to the baddies or you go to kind of like another location or somebody else watching the show. but we stay with Glenn and his, you know, like subjective, intense experience, his point of view. So it was, and, you know, so Glenn was on set every day.
其他类似电影中没有的东西。通常他们会切到坏人，或者你去另一个地点，或者其他人看节目。但我们和格伦待在一起，和他，你知道，主观的、强烈的体验，他的视角。所以，而且，你知道，所以格伦每天都在片场。
Yeah. And he really brought it. It was amazing. But it was an amazing cast all around, like, in fact, I was just talking to a friend of the show, Josh Brolin, who's in the movie, and he said to say hi. The other J.B., the real J.B. Sorry.
是的。他真的表现得很好。太棒了。但周围的演员阵容都很棒，事实上，我刚才正在和节目的朋友乔什·布洛林（Josh Brolin）交谈，他在电影里，他说打个招呼。另一个J.B.，真正的J.B. 对不起。
J.B. We love Josh. We love Josh. Coleman Domingo, Michael Sarah. Michael Sarah. Yeah, Michael Sarah. Your other colleague. First time we've worked together since Scott Pilgrim.
J.B. 我们爱乔什。我们爱乔什。科尔曼·多明戈（Colman Domingo），迈克尔·塞拉（Michael Cera）。迈克尔·塞拉。是的，迈克尔·塞拉。你的另一个同事。自《歪小子斯科特》（Scott Pilgrim）以来我们第一次合作。
Amelia Jones, Jamie Lawson, Sean Hayes is in the movie. Sure, Sean Hayes. Sure. And Julia Cumming, your amazing girlfriend, who's this, she was in the scene with me. And I love her. And she is an incredible singer, and I love her music.
阿米莉亚·琼斯（Amelia Jones），杰米·劳森（Jamie Lawson），肖恩·海耶斯在电影里。当然，肖恩·海耶斯。当然。还有朱莉娅·卡明（Julia Cumming），你出色的女朋友，她是这个，她和我一起在那个场景里。我爱她。她是一位不可思议的歌手，我爱她的音乐。
That's all I wanted to say about that. There you go. Oh, that's all you wanted to say. When do we get to enjoy this film? Yeah. November 14th. Oh, just a time for Thanksgiving. It's coming very soon.
这就是我想说的关于那件事的全部。给你。哦，这就是你想说的全部。我们什么时候能欣赏这部电影？是的。11月14日。哦，正好赶上感恩节。很快就要来了。
It's, I've never made a movie, I don't know if you guys have done, I've never made a movie that's been finished so close to release. Yeah. And it's exciting and nerve-wracking at the same time. But like, it's crazy that, you know, it probably will be finished in like a week's time or something about that, which is wild. I can't wait to see it again. And I read that you can only be. get through directing drinking espresso
这是，我从来没拍过一部电影，我不知道你们是否做过，我从来没拍过一部电影在离上映这么近的时候完成。是的。这既令人兴奋又令人紧张。但是，比如，这很疯狂，你知道，它可能在一周左右的时间内完成，这很狂野。我迫不及待想再看一遍。我读到你只能通过喝浓缩咖啡来完成导演工作。
are you still drinking espresso in post it's way too much way too much it's too much no trouble sleeping yes lots of trouble sleeping I have to knock myself out with melatonin and edibles oh god I'm with you welcome what what do you think
你还在后期制作中喝浓缩咖啡吗？太多了，太多了，太多了。不，睡眠困难，是的，很多睡眠困难。我必须用褪黑素和软糖让自己睡着。哦天哪，我和你一样。欢迎。你觉得
you know it's funny you've done lots of so many things in different areas but comedy's always kind of at the heart of what you do so whether it's horror action there's always the you know comedy's always there have you do you want to get back into
你知道，这很有趣，你做过很多不同领域的事情，但喜剧总是你所做之事的中心，所以无论是恐怖、动作，总是有，你知道，喜剧总是在那里。你想回到
do you have any desire to just go pure comedy again and go into something yeah yeah no I think and also you know as we all know as I'm I'm still want to make movies for the big screen and for some reason at the moment comedy has kind of like sort of like not being made
你有任何渴望回到纯粹的喜剧，进入某种东西吗？是的，是的，不，我想，而且，你知道，正如我们都知道的，因为我仍然想为大银幕制作电影，而且由于某种原因，目前喜剧似乎有点……没有被制作出来。
yeah for like the sort of the cinema anymore which is really strange but I think things are cyclical. I think it will come back. Well, because they always have to have the, and your films have a lot of your films have these big elements to it, and they're very, as Jason pointed out early on, you have a, you have a great visual style and you have a great, and so that's all part of it, it kind of sort of complements the whole thing. But when I go back and I think about space, even now as I'm thinking about how simple it was, and how much it was just on the, you know, the writing
是的，不再为电影院制作了，这真的很奇怪，但我认为事情是周期性的。我认为它会回来的。好吧，因为他们总是必须有，而且你的电影有很多大元素，而且它们非常，正如杰森早先指出的，你有一个伟大的视觉风格，你有一个伟大的，所以这都是其中的一部分，它有点补充了整个事情。但当我回过头来想《屋事生非》时，即使现在我在想它有多简单，以及它在多大程度上只是在……你知道，写作
and the direction, the acting, and just the pure comedy of all. That must be attractive to you on a certain level to kind of get back to something a little simpler in that way? I think so, or it's finding what that is that sort of like, I mean, listen, you know, I'm going to flatter you both, but like, you know, Arrested Development was one of the biggest joke delivery
和导演，表演，以及纯粹的喜剧。这在某种程度上一定对你有吸引力，回到那种更简单的方式？我想是的，或者找到那是什么，那种……我的意思是，听着，你知道，我要恭维你们俩，但比如，你知道，《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）是电视上最大的笑话传递
machines on TV. It had the kind of speed of a Marx Brothers film. And that was the thing that I think when me and Simon, you know, like, would talk about that show all the time, you know, because also American shows at that time when they were network shows, is 22 minutes long, and, like, you know, with, like, 22 minutes and, like, 500 jokes.
机器之一。它有马克思兄弟（Marx Brothers）电影的速度。这就是我认为当我和西蒙，你知道，会一直谈论那个节目时，你知道，因为当时美国的节目，当它们是电视网节目时，是22分钟长，而且，你知道，有22分钟和500个笑话。
Incredible. And I love those things. I mean, I'm still, like, a huge comedy fan and, you know, the best comedy films that just, like, you know, obviously, when I was growing up, things like the Zaka brothers films. Yeah. I shouldn't make Jim Abrams out. But, you know, things like Airplane and Top Secret, those films are huge for me, you know. The Python movies. The Marks brothers, like, just like, I just, I don't know how many times
不可思议。我喜欢那些东西。我的意思是，我仍然是一个巨大的喜剧迷，而且，你知道，最好的喜剧电影，只是，你知道，显然，当我成长时，像扎克兄弟（Zucker brothers）的电影。是的。我不应该把吉姆·亚伯拉罕（Jim Abrahams）排除在外。但是，你知道，像《空前绝后满天飞》（Airplane!）和《最高机密》（Top Secret）这样的东西，这些电影对我来说太重要了，你知道。派森电影。马克思兄弟，就像，我只是，我不知道多少次
I've watched Monkey Business and Duck Soup. Duck Soup, I watched Duck Soup every year's Eve, yeah. It's incredible. It's so funny, for me on the extreme is I used to, Edgar, I suspect you've seen it. And I don't, this is not a recommendation for anybody to watch it because it's very jarring and a lot of people have, but I'm a huge fan of it because it's, I've never seen anything so densely packed, more densely packed with. with jokes, pure just jokes.
我看过《Monkey Business》和《Duck Soup》。《Duck Soup》，我每年除夕都看《Duck Soup》，是的。太不可思议了。太搞笑了，对我来说，在极端情况下，我过去常常，埃德加，我怀疑你看过它。而且我，这不是给任何人看的推荐，因为它非常令人震惊，很多人有，但我是一个巨大的粉丝，因为它，我从来没见过比这更密集的东西，更密集地充满了
And again, a lot of it, people, I've had people react with tears in their eyes because they feel so jarred by it. Xavier Renegate Angel. Oh, you know what? I have never seen this show, but Bill Hader talks about it all the time. Hader loves it too. I didn't, like, a lot of the adult swim shows
笑话，纯粹的笑话。而且再一次，很多人，我见过人们眼含泪水，因为他们觉得它太令人震惊了。《Xavier: Renegade Angel》。哦，你知道吗？我从来没看过这个节目，但比尔·哈德（Bill Hader）一直谈论它。哈德也喜欢它。我没有，比如，很多Adult Swim的节目
never made it over to the UK. The guys who did wonder shows, and, uh... Oh yeah, I have seen that. Vernon Chapman and, and, uh, what's name, John Lee, they did. It is a absolutely, you want to talk about wall-to-wall jokes. There's nothing else but jokes, and it's also very disturbing. This is an animated show?
从来没有传到英国。做《Wonder Showzen》的那些人，还有……哦是的，我看过那个。弗农·查普曼（Vernon Chatman）和，还有，叫什么名字，约翰·李（John Lee），他们做的。这是一个绝对的，你想谈论满墙的笑话。除了笑话什么都没有，而且它也非常令人不安。这是一个动画节目吗？
Yeah, I send this with a big warning. There's a big warning about it, because people will, people, they'll end up responding to this episode with tears in their eyes. Like, man, you really fight me up with that executive, Renegate Angel. Oh, really? Holy shit. Anyway, sorry, that's just an aside. Edgar, what's the best, we'll leave on this. what's the best piece of advice you've got
是的，我带着一个大警告发送这个。有一个关于它的大警告，因为人们会，人们，他们最终会眼含泪水地回应这一集。就像，伙计，你真的用那个《Xavier: Renegade Angel》让我兴奋起来了。哦，真的吗？天哪。无论如何，抱歉，那只是一个题外话。埃德加，什么是最好的，我们以此结束。你得到的最好的建议
and the worst? Oh, God, the worst advice. The best and worst was from a guy who used to run a big studio. He said, be patient, just be patient. Which is the best and the worst. Best advice? And the worst. And the worst. It's both.
和最坏的？哦，天哪，最坏的建议。最好和最坏的来自一个过去经营大制片厂的人。他说，要有耐心，只要有耐心。这是最好和最坏的。最好的建议？还有最坏的。还有最坏的。两者都是。
It is. I wish I had a great pithy answer for this. I remember somebody said to me that, I mean, I say to people at the time, because sometimes I feel that people make movies and they're making movies to kind of fulfill a brief.
是的。我希望我对此有一个伟大的简洁答案。我记得有人对我说，我的意思是，我当时对人们说，因为有时我觉得人们拍电影，他们拍电影是为了完成一个简报。
I think you, and I don't if everybody ever says, but you have to be the cinema, you have to make the movie that you want to see as a customer. And so I'm always, and so, I mean, I can't believe I'm like telling you advice that I give them myself, or give them to other people,
我认为你，我不知道是否每个人都说过，但你必须成为电影，你必须制作你想作为顾客看到的电影。所以我总是，而且，我的意思是，我不敢相信我像是在告诉你我自己给他们的建议，或者给其他人，
but it is that thing as I think, that's the thing that I think about all the time is I want to be the audience member. And I think as a film director, you're always just chasing that thrill of the of the film that you saw or the film that you want to see that if you didn't make this film
但这就是我一直想的事情，我想成为观众。我认为作为电影导演，你总是只是在追逐那种你看到的电影的快感，或者你想看到的电影，如果你不拍这部电影
yourself, you would want to be the biggest fan of it. And I think that's something is just, I haven't really answered you a question, Sean. But I think that's always the thing that I return to is just to sort of try and be sincere in the process of make the movie that you would want to see. Instead of trying to guess what they want.
你自己，你会想成为它最大的粉丝。我认为这就是某件事，我没有真正回答你的问题，肖恩。但我认为这总是我回归的事情，就是尝试在制作过程中真诚，制作你想看到的电影。而不是试图猜测他们想要什么。
Yeah. Yeah, because I think that comes up. I think you can tell those movies where people are kind of working in genres that they don't necessarily love. I think you can tell I think when people like really love what they're doing it's palpable and it's infectious
是的。是的，因为我觉得这确实会出现。我觉得你能看出那些电影，人们在某种程度上是在从事他们并不一定热爱的类型。我觉得你能看出来，当人们真正热爱他们所做的事情时，那种感觉是显而易见的，而且具有感染力。
I bet you have those moments I'm kind of visualizing you having a moment like do you can you remember moments maybe on Running Man where you there's a big moment or a big shot or something happened and when you yell cut you're like fuck yes yeah yeah well you never people always say like
我敢说你也有过这样的时刻，我正在想象你经历过这样的时刻，你还记得吗，也许是在《奔跑者》拍摄期间，有一个重要的时刻或一个重要的镜头，或者发生了什么事，当你喊“卡”的时候，你会说“去他的，太棒了，耶”。嗯，你从来不会……人们总是说，比如
I mean even on comedies especially they say like oh you guys look like you're having such a blast And you always say, well, you never have time, you know, on a schedule to stand around and high-five each other afterwards. It's like even after the most famous bit in the film, like when the film comes out, you know, on the day, it's like, okay, so now we're going to put the camera over here and now we're going to get this shot.
我的意思是，即使是在喜剧片中，尤其是他们会说，哦，你们看起来玩得真开心。而你总是说，嗯，在拍摄日程中，你从来没有时间站在那里互相击掌。就像电影中最著名的片段拍完后，当电影上映时，你知道，在那一天，就像是，好吧，现在我们要把摄像机放在这里，现在我们要拍这个镜头。
And, you know, Jason, you know this. It's just you're always moving on to the next thing. But then you see it in the editing room, but it's just you and the editor. And you're like, oh, God, I wish I had them all around to watch this right now, what they've all created. Yeah. I think the times that you have that.
而且，你知道，杰森，你懂的。你总是忙着进行下一项工作。但后来你在剪辑室看到它时，只有你和剪辑师在场。你会想，哦，天哪，我真希望他们都在这里看着这一切，看着他们共同创造的东西。是的。我想你拥有那种时刻的时候，
moment, actually, is when you're doing a scene in one take. Because then, I think what happens is the whole crew crowds around the monitor, because like, did we get it? Did it work? And there are quite a few, like, oners in The Running Man. So those are usually the
其实，就是当你一镜到底拍摄一个场景的时候。因为那时，我想发生的事情是整个剧组都围在监视器旁，因为大家都在想，我们拍到了吗？成功了吗？在《奔跑者》中确实有不少一镜到底的镜头。所以那些通常是
times when the crew really bond over something is like, you know, Baby Driver, like, the opening credits of the film is like a three minute take and with lots of choreography and, you know, so everybody crowds around the monitor. to see whether it works and whether we got it. So I think those are the moments, I think,
剧组真正因为某件事而建立联系的时刻，就像《极盗车神》，电影的开场字幕是一个三分钟的长镜头，有很多编排，你知道，所以每个人都围在监视器旁，看看它是否有效，我们是否拍到了。所以我认为那些就是时刻，我想，
where usually everything else is you or just shooting, shooting, shooting, and then, like, you know, it's the end of the day. Well, you can really tell how much you love what you do, watching your stuff. You're one of the most exciting filmmakers that we have, Edgar. It's truly a joy watching everything that you do. I cannot wait to see anything, man.
通常其他时候你只是在拍摄、拍摄、拍摄，然后，你知道，一天就结束了。嗯，看你的作品真的能看出你有多热爱你的工作。埃德加，你是我们拥有的最令人兴奋的电影制作人之一。看你所做的一切真是一种享受。我迫不及待地想看任何东西了，伙计。
It's been awesome, and you've been so supportive of us. You were one of the first people to tell you. me when we started doing this podcast years ago and you've always been so sweet about it. Well, it made me just hanging out with you guys. We'll get back to us. It was in the middle of the pandemic and then I start texting you, I was saying, oh, I miss you, but then I hear you every week
这太棒了，你一直非常支持我们。你是几年前我们刚开始做这个播客时最早告诉我们的人之一，你一直对此非常贴心。嗯，这让我只是和你们在一起。我们会回到我们身上。那是在疫情期间，然后我开始给你发短信，我说，哦，我想你了，但我每周都能听到你的声音，
it feels like in my life and stuff. Well, finish up your post and get back out of it. I'm going to be in London in 10 days and I'm going to text you. You know what? I have tickets to see is this thing on? Oh, you'll love it. It's such a good movie. You'll love it. Unless I'm mixing, I'll be there.
感觉就像在我的生活中一样。好了，完成你的后期制作，然后回来吧。我10天后要去伦敦，我会给你发短信的。你知道吗？我有票去看……这个东西在放映吗？哦，你会喜欢的。这是一部非常好的电影。你会喜欢的。除非我在混音，否则我会去的。
Great. Great, please be there. But no, I actually got tickets ahead of time. I was going to tell you that. I'll see you in London. I can't wait to see you. Oh, good. I hope you come.
太好了。太好了，请一定要去。但没有，我其实提前买到了票。我正要告诉你。我会在伦敦见到你。我迫不及待想见到你了。哦，太好了。我希望你能来。
I hope you come. And we always say, like, you know, everybody check out whatever movie or whatever somebody's promoting. But I don't have to tell people to check out The Running Man because just watch the trailer, people are going to come. It's incredible. I'm so excited for the Running Man.
我希望你能来。我们总是说，你知道，每个人都去看看某人正在宣传的任何电影或任何东西。但我不需要告诉人们去看看《奔跑者》，因为只要看预告片，人们就会来的。这太不可思议了。我为《奔跑者》感到非常兴奋。
It's incredible. I am so excited to see this film. Let me put it this way. The guy who got the film Green Lit is on the call. Hey, all. Wow. Bravo, bravo. Wait, really quick.
这太不可思议了。我非常兴奋能看到这部电影。让我这样说吧。让这部电影获得绿灯的人就在通话中。嘿，大家好。哇。太棒了，太棒了。等等，很快。
Paramount, we're like, we're not sure about this at this budget level, and they said, John Hayes is in? Yeah, okay. Here we go. Check, check, check, check. But we did really quick. We saw Giant, a couple years ago, you're like, let's go see Giant with Rock Hudson and James Dean.
派拉蒙当时说，我们不确定这个预算水平是否合适，他们说，约翰·海耶斯参与了吗？是的，好吧。我们开始吧。支票，支票，支票，支票。但我们确实很快。我们几年前看了《巨人传》，你说，我们去看罗克·赫德森和詹姆斯·迪恩主演的《巨人传》吧。
At the Vista. At the Vista, right. And we go, and I, because I knew you had a sweet tooth, too, because you had Junior Mint sent to the set of Baby Driver. And I go to the lobby, and I get a pack of Swedish fish, finish them, and go get another one, another packet of Swedish fish. And you turn to me and you go,
在维斯塔剧院。在维斯塔，对。我们去了，而且我因为知道你也爱吃甜食，因为你给《极盗车神》的片场送过朱尼尔薄荷糖。我走到大厅，买了一包瑞典鱼软糖，吃完了，又去买了一包，又一包瑞典鱼软糖。你转过身对我说，
Wow, so it's really true. The lights have gone out again. This must be here. Anyway, we love you. Thank you for being here, Edgar. It's so nice to see your faces. It's so good to see you, man. I'll see you all soon in person.
哇，所以这是真的。灯又灭了。这一定是在这里。总之，我们爱你。谢谢你来到这里，埃德加。见到你们的脸真好。见到你真好，伙计。我很快就会亲自见到你们所有人。
Thanks for doing this, after. Love you, pal. So good to see you. Love you, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. I'm going to do the traditional slamming of the laptop. Oh, yeah. There you go. That, Edgar.
谢谢你做这一切，之后。爱你，伙计。见到你真好。爱你，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见。我要做传统的合上笔记本电脑的动作。哦，是的。就是这样。那个，埃德加。
I mean, he's just, you know, I called you a, stuffed animal with blood on my recent press tour as an attempt to say the most flattering thing I could possibly say about you because you're so goddamn sweet but he would be the stuffed animal with blood that's sitting right next to you yeah he's the on the daybed he's such a good guy such a good person such a good person so sweet always been he's always so warm and then it sort of it betrays like this
我的意思是，他只是，你知道，我在最近的媒体巡回宣传中称你为“沾着血的毛绒玩具”，试图说出我能对你说的最恭维的话，因为你太该死地贴心了，但他会是坐在你旁边的那个沾着血的毛绒玩具，是的，他在沙发床上，他真是个好人，这么好的人，这么好的人，这么贴心，一直都是，他总是那么温暖，然后这似乎背叛了像这种
incredible talent yeah I know and one of our great filmmakers you know I know I love him to watch him do his thing on set. It's so fun. He's so, like, calm. And he brings people together, too. I mean, he did, right? You know, he's introduced us to so many of our friends that we became friends with over the years,
不可思议的天赋，是的，我知道，我们伟大的电影制作人之一，你知道，我知道，我喜欢看他在片场做他的事情。太有趣了。他那么，冷静。而且他也把人们聚在一起。我的意思是，他做到了，对吧？你知道，他把我们介绍给了我们多年来成为朋友的许多朋友，
certainly to me and, you know, lifelong friends, pizza, in which, obviously, we mentioned before and all those guys in Simon. He's just such a great people person. Yeah. You know, he's just such a great person. Yep. Yeah.
当然对我来说，你知道，终生的朋友，披萨，我们之前显然提到过，还有西蒙的那些人。他真是个很棒的善于交际的人。是的。你知道，他真是个很棒的人。是的。是的。
Good friend. Jason, Jason, you look like. Jason, you look like... You look like you have to go. I was grinding on a bye right then, but... I know. None of them seemed really good enough. Yeah, I know.
好朋友。杰森，杰森，你看起来。杰森，你看起来……你看起来好像必须得走了。我当时正在努力想一个再见的话，但是……我知道。没有一个看起来真的足够好。是的，我知道。
You got it. Is there anything that was sort of coming close? Well, he's a great person who brings a bunch of people together and makes it really hard to say goodbye to those people. But that's just too literal. You've got to commit. I mean, the fact of he lives in England and also in America. No, don't do that.
你做到了。有什么接近的东西吗？嗯，他是一个把一群人聚在一起，让人很难对那些人说再见的伟大的人。但这太字面意思了。你必须投入。我的意思是，他住在英国，也住在美洲的事实。不，别那样做。
This one. By country. Oh, we haven't used that one. He's by continental. I mean, it's loose. It's loose, but it'll work. Good boy. Talk about loose.
这个。按国家。哦，我们还没用过那个。他是双洲的。我的意思是，这很松散。这很松散，但它会起作用。好孩子。谈谈松散。
Speaking of loose. Smartless. Smart. Yes. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted. by Bennett Barbicoe, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf. Smart less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
说到松散。Smartless。Smart。是的。Smartless。Smartless是由本内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·阿姆朱夫手工制作的100%有机产品。Smartless。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。